Hey, welcome to smart list. I'm Jason. Hi, welcome to smart list. I'm Will. Hi, welcome to smart list. My name is Sean. Tell you what, I'm going to do the welcome to smart list and tell him Jason and then you just go Will and Sean. Hey, I'm welcome to smart. No. Hi, I'm welcome. Oh, that was real. Hi, I'm welcome to smart list. Hi, smart list. How are you? Oh, little smart list showed up today. He's crying. Well, goodness, smart list, smarty pants. I love both of my dogs, but I am not embarrassed to tell you or maybe I am embarrassed to tell you. I love them and love them and love them. I'll get my hands all over them, but I wash my hands immediately after I touch my dogs. Way to go. Because people who are like dog people and animal
嘿，欢迎收看 SmartLess。我是杰森。嗨，欢迎收看 SmartLess。我是威尔。嗨，欢迎收看 SmartLess。我叫肖恩。跟你说吧，我来主持欢迎收看 SmartLess，然后说我是杰森，接着你就说威尔和肖恩。嘿，我是欢迎收看 Smart... 不。嗨，我是欢迎。哦，那是真的。嗨，欢迎收看 SmartLess。嗨，SmartLess。你好吗？哦，小 SmartLess 今天来了。他在哭。天哪，SmartLess，小机灵鬼。我爱我的两只狗，但我毫不尴尬地告诉你，或者也许我很尴尬地告诉你。我爱它们，爱它们，爱它们。我会把双手在它们身上揉搓，但我一摸完狗就会立刻洗手。做得好。因为那些真正喜欢狗和动物的人，
people, they're not really, they're not really vocal and stuff. So way to go. Wait for the letters from the dog. You know, you should allow and this and that. What do you mean? No, no, we love them. I'm just preempting. We loved our dogs. But I went over to a friend's house the other day and these, these, these folks, they, they have the rule where you got to take off your shoes and you go in and I get that. I understand that. But their dogs are running around all over the place. Hey, Mitch, good to see you. Oh no, there's our guest. This thing fell off. Is that Mitch? It's the first time it's ever happened, you guys. Jesus, how embarrassing. All right. This is the first. Our, our Mr. Guest usually covers their camera and then the, the
他们并不是真的，并不是真的会把这些说出来什么的。所以做得好。等着收狗发来的信吧。你知道的，你应该允许这啊那的。你什么意思？不，不，我们爱它们。我只是先发制人。我们爱我们的狗。但我前几天去一个朋友家，这帮人，这帮人，他们有个规矩，就是你得脱鞋才能进去，我懂这个。我理解这个。但他们的狗在四处乱跑。嘿，米奇，很高兴见到你。哦不，我们的嘉宾来了。这东西掉下来了。那是米奇吗？你们这可是破天荒头一次。天哪，太尴尬了吧。好吧。这可是头一遭。我们的，我们的特邀嘉宾通常会挡住他们的摄像头，然后，邀请嘉宾的人会做一个很长的开场白，做很高的铺垫，接着嘉宾再露面。但是米奇有一叠旧便签纸，我猜，上面的胶水已经不太灵了。好吧，我把它们擦干净又重新利用了。好吧，那是谁的嘉宾？这是我的嘉宾。你知道吗，米奇？你知道的，现在就介绍他吧。他们是听众。不，我不打算，米奇，介绍，米奇，介绍一下你自己。介绍一下你自己。对。那是对你的惩罚。对。大家好。我是米奇。我当然认得你们，迈克尔·布鲁斯和乔·布鲁斯。当然还有乔治·迈克尔·布鲁斯。真是难得的享受。不，不，不，不。不，这是肖恩·海斯。不，但是，对于听众来说，米奇·赫维茨是《发展受阻》的才华横溢的创作者。欢迎米奇·赫维茨。
person who invited the guest as a big intro, as a big buildup and then they reveal themselves. But Mitch has an old stack of post-its, I guess, that have not real good adhesive on them. Well, I erased them and I reused them. Well, who's guest is it? This is my guest. And you know what, Mitch? You know, introduce him now. They're listeners. No, I'm not going to, Mitch, introduce, Mitch, introduce yourself. Introduce yourself. Yeah. That's your penalty. Yeah. Hi guys. I'm Mitch. I obviously recognize you, Michael Bluth and Joe Bluth. And of course, George Michael Bluth. What a treat. No, no, no, no. No, it's Sean Hayes. No, but for, for the people listening, Mitch Hurwitz is the brilliant creator of Arrested Development. Welcome, Mitch Hurwitz.
欢迎米奇·赫维茨。我觉得听众没听明白。米奇·赫维茨是《发展受阻》这部剧创作之翼下的清风，是整个好莱坞最聪明、最搞笑的人。好莱坞最差的秘密保守者，他们都这么叫我。最差的秘密，对。他，那是历史上最烂的出场方式。这是我们做过最烂的开场。而且居然还是跟米奇一起。好吧，让我们，让我们把演技拿出来测试一下。好。让我们听听，让我们听听，重来一次。听听原本的开场应该是什么样的。我们来。我们来。再把摄像头挡上。我把，我把摄像头挡上了。崭新的便签。好。他要挡住摄像头了。我们从头再来一遍。预备，开始。嘿，伙计们。所以，我真的很兴奋。我摔倒了。
Welcome, Mitch Hurwitz. I don't think the listener got that. Mitch Hurwitz is the, the wind beneath the creative wings of Arrested Development, the smartest, funniest man in all of Hollywood. Worst secret keeper in Hollywood, they call me. Worst secret, yeah. He's, that was the worst reveal in history. This is the worst opening we've ever had. And of course it's with Mitch. Well, let's, let's put our acting chops to the test. Okay. Let's hear, let's hear, let's take it. Let's hear what the intro would have been. Here we go. Here we go. Cover the camera again. I'm covering up the, I'm covering up the camera. Brand new post. Okay. He's going to cover the camera. Let's go back through it. And here we go. Action. Hey guys. So I'm really excited. I fell down.
不，你要等开场白，米奇，等开场白。等他说你的名字。等。等我说，不。等开场白。我不是演员。不，显然不是。我们会聊到这个。我们等下，别。我不在那。重点是我不在那，伙计们。好吧。嘿，威尔，你的嘉宾是谁？好吧，伙计们，我今天的嘉宾是，我很高兴我们的嘉宾能来。你知道，你喜欢，你喜欢《黄金女郎》。我喜欢女郎们。你们找来了，呃，你们没有找来 Bea Arthur 的鬼魂吧？好吧，我，我立刻开始想，等等，谁还活着？谁死了？哇。好吧。别笑了，米奇。你根本不准笑。哦，等等，嘉宾的名字叫米奇吗？不，不是。不。你看，现在你又搞砸了。我知道。但再试一次。所以我们的第一嘉宾，
No, you're going to wait for the intro, Mitch, wait for the intro. Wait till he says your name. Wait till, wait. Wait till I say no. Wait for the intro. I'm not an actor. No, clearly. We'll get into that. We'll get, don't. I'm not here. The point is I'm not here, guys. Okay. Hey, Will, who's your guest? Yeah. So guys, my guest today is, I'm really excited to have our guest on. You know, you love, you love the golden girls. I love the girls. Did you get, uh, you, we did not get the ghost of B Arthur. Okay. We, I immediately started to think, wait, who's alive? And who's, wow. Okay. Stop laughing, Mitch. You're not even allowed to laugh. Oh, wait, is the guest name Mitch? No, it's not. No. See, now you're blowing it. I know. But try again. So our first guest,
啊，操，这是我们唯一的嘉宾。呃，我们今天的嘉宾是一个曾经当了很多年编剧的人，是米奇·欧文斯。他又把自己曝光了。如果我带一个嘉宾进来，会不合适吗？是的。给我们换个新搭档怎么样？我，但这里，这里有一点应该指出。我们尝试重现的每一次。不，没什么好指出的。我们赶紧把这事办完吧。好吧。有什么华丽的，有什么华丽的开场白？把你刚才想说的那些好听的话都说出来。他写过，他写过《黄金》。他从威特·托马斯公司的跑腿开始做起，最后负责《黄金女郎》。他做过《黄金宫殿》。他写过上百万部剧。然后在2003年，他创造了一部剧，给杰森和我带来了超乎我们最大胆的
ah, fuck, it's our only guest. Uh, our guest today is a guy who started as a writer of many moons of, it's Mitch Erwin. He just revealed himself again. Would it be inappropriate if I were to bring in a guest? Yes. How about a new co-host for us? I, but here's, here's what should be noted. Every one of those times that we tried to recreate. No, there's no, there's nothing to note. Let's just get this over with. Yeah. What's the glowing, what's the glowing intro? Say all the nice things you were about to say about that. He wrote on, he wrote on golden. He started as a runner at Whit Thomas and ended up running golden girls. He did golden palace. He's written a million shows. And then in 2003, he created a show that gave both Jason and me a life beyond our wildest
梦想的生活。哦，拜了个拜。他是个不可思议的编剧。他是个了不起的父亲，他可能是我相处过最搞笑的人。我很幸运能称呼我的朋友这位了不起的。我猜不出这是谁。等等，让我想想。因艾美奖而陶醉的米奇·赫维茨。现在我要静音并挡住摄像头，然后让你们自己聊。现在别这么做。现在别。不，别这样。千万别静音。哦，米奇。米奇，你周六在干什么呢？好吧，你知道的，这是，我提前录好了我的部分，所以我今天有空。你怎么知道这些问题的？我想让自己看起来最年轻，然后我只是觉得，你知道，我知道一周后会有这个节目，我想也许我可以提前一周准备。
dreams. Oh, please. He's an incredible writer. He's a phenomenal father and he's potentially the funniest person I've ever spent time with. And I'm lucky enough to call my friend the incredible. I can't guess who this is. Wait, wait, let me guess. Drunk on Emmy Award, Mitch Erwitz. And now I'm just going to mute and cover my camera and just let you guys go. Don't do it now. Don't do it now. No, don't do it. Do not mute. Oh, Mitch. Mitch, what are you doing on a Saturday? Well, you know, this is, I pre-recorded my part, so I'm free today. How did you know the questions? I wanted to look my youngest and I just thought, you know, I knew it was coming up in a week and I thought maybe I just get a week on it.
你看起来确实很好。你最近都在做什么？你看起来身材很好，水分充足。对，我猜我很水润。是吗？对，自从我们一起工作以来，我喝了很多水。我是说，我可能，好吧，这听起来像是在吹牛，但自从我们上次合作以来，我大概喝了15、20加仑的水。哦，天哪。是的。其实那不算太多，因为已经过去一会儿了。不算多吗？不，不算多。好吧。好吧，我知道我很渴。而且是一口气喝完的？肖恩，你知道肖恩送过花吗？你还记得你曾经送过我花吗？哦，对了。因为他以为你死了还是怎么的？是这么回事吗？不，不。我，我有一段时间在收集花。不，正如我讲这个故事时所意识到的，
You actually do look very good. What do you've been doing? You look fit and hydrated. Yeah, I guess I'm hydrated. Yeah? Yeah, I've been drinking a lot of water since we worked together. I mean, I probably, well, it's going to sound like I'm bragging, but I probably drank about 15, 20 gallons of water since we last worked together. Oh, Lord. Yeah. That's actually not that much because it's been a minute. Is it not much? No, it's not much. Okay. Well, I know I am very thirsty. And one sitting? Sean, do you know that Sean sent flowers? Do you remember that you sent me flowers once? Oh, right. Because he thought you died or something? Was that what happened? No, no. I had, I was collecting flowers for a while. No, as I realized, as I told this story,
我意识到根本没有好方法来讲述这个故事。他是个很会送花的人。这点我承认。那是为了庆祝我们共同合作。肖恩，我得为此对你说声谢谢。真的吗，肖恩？你欠我花吗？他从来没给你送过花吗？老实说，肖恩从来没给你送过花吗？好吧，我？对。不，那是他必须做的事吗？不，但我送过他孩子的礼物，却从来没有听到任何回音。这不是真的。这不是真的。想得美。肖恩，这里，我能告诉你另一件事吗？我们差点发生的另一次互动。那是1998年，我正在为一部名为《一切皆有亲戚》的剧选角。我拿下了吗？不，你没来。当时的情况是……我确实去试镜了，但我想我没通过
I realized that there's no good way to tell the story. He's a good flower sender. I will give him that. It was a congratulations for our work together. And Sean, I owe you a thank you for that. Is that true, Sean? Are you owe me flowers? Has he never sent you flowers? Well, honestly, has Sean never sent you flowers? Well, me? Yeah. No, is that something that he has to do? No, but I've sent his kids gifts and never heard anything. That's not true. That's not true. Nice try. Sean, here's, can I tell you one other thing? One other interaction we almost had. So it's 1998 and I'm trying to cast a show called Everything's Relative. And did I get it? No, you didn't come in. What had happened was... I did audition for it, but I didn't get past
那个选角记录。真他妈的。等等。我要给你打个电话。哦，这是米奇的举手。你现在在打电话吗？这看起来有点……好吧，肖恩很棒。不，他是很棒。不，那部剧本该播出的。好吧。对，当时的情况是我找不到合适的人来演这个角色，我什么都试过了。然后我不知道你曾经试镜过，因为我曾对选角导演说，嘿，多力多滋广告里有个家伙看起来挺搞笑的。我觉他就是那个人，然后他们说，好吧，米奇。那个表现得对那个女孩很有好感的人。不，不是那个女孩。是你。不，我在那个多力多滋广告里表现得对那个女孩很有好感。老实说，你看起来对多力多滋更有好感。我是的。嘿，米奇，那也是
that casting record, I think. God damn it. Hold on. I'm gonna make your call. Oh, here's Mitch's raise. Are you making the call now? This seems a little... Well, Sean's great. No, he is great. No, that show would be on the air. Okay. Right. Well, what happened was I could not cast this part and I just tried everything. And then I didn't know that you ever auditioned because I had said to the casting director, hey, there's a guy in a Doritos commercial that looks really funny. And I think he's the guy and they were like, okay, Mitch. Who was acting like he's into the girl. No, it wasn't the girl. It was you. No, I was acting like I was into the girl in that Doritos commercial. You look like you were more into the Doritos, to be honest. I was. Hey, Mitch, was that the
我试镜过的剧吗？是的。然后我们终于选定了一个人。你们选了谁？我们选了一位非常棒的演员，名叫凯文·拉姆。他演过《广告狂人》，也演过这个。他上过《SmartLess》大约三次。每次都给你们其中不同的人带来惊喜。你们不记得了。所以我们终于选定了他，这确实是一个漫长的过程。然后他们说，杰森·贝特曼会来。杰森来了，读了剧本，我记得当时想，靠，他太棒了。不。他太棒了。但我不能再回去了。这样如何？杰森会来，但肖恩要求也来。但这是不是那个试镜，后来当你为《发展受阻》选角而我因为身上带着太多情景喜剧的包袱而并不适合，而你们当时正试图做一些比那更酷的事情时，你实际上说，不，不，我让他来读剧本，因为我记得几年前我选角的一部剧里他读得很棒？如果不是因为这个，我可能都不会被选上《发展受阻》，还是这只是我自己的脑补？据我回忆，你知道，这些事情都太……你看出我是怎么想的了吗？但我记得我想让你来，因为我知道你有多优秀，同时又有点担心他们会说，哦，我们就选杰森·贝特曼吧，因为你那时已经拍了很多试播集了。我想，好吧，但我想让他读一读，我想，你知道，我要确保它是对的。但正如你所知，你来了，再一次，
show that I auditioned for too? Yes. So then we finally cast somebody. Who'd you cast? We cast a wonderful actor named Kevin Rahm. He's been in Mad Men and he's been on this. He's been on Smart List about three times. Each time surprised a different one of you. You don't remember this. So we had finally cast it and it really had been a long process. And then they said, Jason Bateman will come in. And Jason came in and read and I remember thinking, shit, he's great. No. He's great. But I couldn't go back one more time. How about this? Jason will come in, but Sean's asking to come in. But was this the audition that when later, when you were casting Arrested Development and I was not right for it because I brought a lot of sitcom baggage with
我是说就在几秒钟内，我找到了那个试镜。你发给我的。如果我把它放给你看，好吧，我下次见到你的时候应该放给你看。米奇把当年我为《发展受阻》试镜的录像带发给我了。哇。从某种意义上说，这让我很触动。真的把我震撼到了。为什么？在什么方面？嗯，因为那是保存在我胶片上的那个时刻。但那是杰森真正还是杰森的最后时刻吗，就在《发展受阻》之前？也许这就是它如此感人的原因。就像一个真正的家伙。对，就像一个真正的男孩。不，他进来了，最神奇的是，我必须放给你们看。我希望我们能，好吧，我们播一下那个片段。哦，靠。不，不，我们在做播客。这是播客。我们不能播。我们不播
me and you guys were trying to do something cooler than that, you actually said, no, no, I'll read him because I remember he gave a good reading for a show I was casting years ago. And were it not for that, I may not have been seen for Arrested Development or is that my own narrative? As I recall, you know, these things are so... Do you see the way I mean it about me? But I remember wanting you to come in because I knew how good you were and simultaneously being a little worried that they would just say, oh, we'll just take Jason Bateman because you had done a lot of pilots at that point. And I thought, well, but I want to read him and I want to, you know, I want to make sure it's right. But as you know, you came in and once again,
片段。这是播客。我他妈在播客里干什么呢？这是个好问题。我们当中谁在干什么呢？所以所有关于我外表的言论，谁也看不见我。他们只能相信我们的话。不，不，不。但他们相信了。他们相信了。不过听起来你水分很充足。好了。我把这副牙齿拿掉。等一下。等等，米奇，你看起来很喜欢演员，演员也很喜欢你。你喜欢演员吗？你喜欢和伟大的演员、难搞的演员以及介于两者之间的演员合作吗？我想是的。我喜欢和有创意的人一起玩。我只想把关于杰森的故事做个收尾。我们回到那个话题吧。让他说完，伙计们。我只是得说出来。我希望人们能看到它，因为最引人注目的是，那是杰森，带着他所有的
I mean just within seconds and I found the audition. You sent me that. If I showed this to you, well, I should show this to you next time I see you. Mitch sent me the videotape of my audition for Arrested Development. Wow. It's very touching to me in a way. It really knocked me out. Why? In what way? Well, because that's what I have on film, the moment. But is that the last time Jason was really Jason, like right before Arrested Development? Maybe that's what was so touching about it. It was like a real guy. Yeah, like a real boy. No, he came in and what's amazing, I have to show it to you. I wish we could, well, let's run the clip. Oh, shit. No, no, we're on a podcast. This is a podcast. We can't run it. We're not running
魅力、低调的才华和独特的专注力。我是说，他有一种我真的，你很少见演员有的特质。他从第一刻起就完全投入其中。金钱。谈钱确实显得有点早。我很惊讶我们这么快就谈到这个。你当时就像是，你喜欢那个吗？你喜欢那个吗？我这个可以给你打折。我可以给你那个。只要你出得起价，我一整天都可以给你那个。我余生的开始。但他看起来不一样。你当时留着长发。你有点，更随性一点。你在演那个角色。没有像迈克尔·布鲁斯巅峰时期那样紧绷。我们都在祈求那一天的回归。哦，是的。我们迫不及待地想让随性的杰森回来。随性的杰森，我们从2004年就开始等了。为了随性的杰森。你知道我
clips. It's a podcast. What the fuck am I doing on a podcast? That's a great question. What are any of us? So all that stuff about how I look, nobody can see me. They have to take our word for it. No, no, no. But they're taking it. They're taking it. You sound hydrated though. All right. I'm taking these teeth out. Hold on a second. Wait, Mitch, you seem like you love actors and actors love you. Do you love actors? Do you love working with the great ones and the difficult ones and the ones in between? I suppose I do. I'd love playing with creative people. And I just want to round out the story about Jason. Let's get back to that. Let him finish, guys. I just have to say it. I wish people could see it because what's so striking about it is there's Jason with all
记得去参加那个试镜的时候，当我终于去见电视台的人，而杰森，你也在那里，我当时，我不知道我对你是谁有什么样的概念。毫无疑问，你是一个已经干了很久的人，在我看来你就像是个洛杉矶内部人士，你知道所有人。你了解这个流程。你拍了无数的戏。而我是一个他妈的无名小卒，只是想找份工作。我想，那是，但你是一个，而最神奇的是，你一见到你，你就那么热情。你那么慷慨，而且，抱歉，我们在谈论我还是米奇？你。哦，那继续。对我来说，这是个谈论你们的完美工作。我以为你在说米奇。好吧，米奇犯了个错误，就在我准备去参加电视台的试镜之前，他对我说了，我记得那是个星期一早上，我飞到了洛杉矶，他说，你肯定能拿下这个。所以听着，我说，别这么说。你疯了吗？好吧，我之后说的那句话才真正糟糕，导致你没拿到。他本不该拿到这个的。不，那件事我至今想起来都睡不着觉。他出来了。我，我立刻就喜欢上了他，就像我喜欢杰森一样。你知道，我只是，你知道，威尔？威尔·阿奈特从试镜里走出来了，或者，我猜你是第一个离开的，然后我走出了房间，我抓住他，我说，你拿下了。你拿下了。他们爱你。然后我往左一看，还有两个家伙在等着。其中一个是雷恩。威尔逊是个很棒的演员，我是说，他后来发展得也挺好。
his charisma and his understated talent and his unique focus. I mean, he has this thing that I really, you sell them seeing actors. He's just in it for the first moment. Money. It did seem early to negotiate. I was surprised that we went so quickly into that. You were like, did you like that? Did you like that? I can give you a deal on this. I can give you that. I can give you that all day long for a price. The start of the rest of my life. But he looks different. Your hair was long. You're kind of a little looser. You were playing the character. It wasn't as kind of uptight as Michael Bluthpeak came. We're all begging for that day back. Oh, yeah. We can't wait for Loose Jason to come back. Loose Jason, we've been waiting for since 2004. For Loose Jason. You know what I
对。如果他得到了乔布的角色，他就不会演《办公室》，也不会有那么长的演艺生涯了。哦，当时在场的人都很棒，但他们是，但你知道选角是怎么回事。我经常希望演员们能体验一下站在选角办公桌的另一边是什么感觉，因为，或者在我的情况下，是沙发、床或者是个折叠床。我们有个折叠床。我们不能再那样做了。再也不能了，再也不能了，再也不能了，再也不能了。好吧，如果是对男演员就可以，对吧？别拿这个开玩笑道。哦，可以的。不，不可以。好吧。你甚至不能开玩笑。我能用有性别歧视的语言吗？可以。如果你，所以你是说如果演员们能看到这个过程的另一边，就不会那么令人生畏了？我猜，我是说，你得告诉我，但我猜对于你们早期的职业生涯来说，这些全都是
remember going into that audition when I finally went to the network and Jason, you were there and I was, I don't know what kind of notion I had about who you were. Definitely you were a guy who'd been doing it a long time and you seemed like a sort of LA insider guy to me that like, you knew everybody. You knew the process. You'd worked a ton. I was a fucking nobody who was just trying to get a job. And I was like, that's, but you were such a, and what's amazing is the second you meet you, you're so warm. You're so giving and, and, sorry, we're talking about me or Mitch. You. Oh, so keep going. This is a perfect job for me to talk about you guys. I thought you were talking about Mitch. Well, Mitch made the mistake of saying to me, we're right before, right before I was going to go
幸运的是，谢天谢地，对你们来说已经是遥远的记忆了，但那种，试镜前做了大量的准备工作，然后有大量的，你知道的，你专注于自己，大量的自我审视，然后你走进去了，可能没有完全按计划发挥，你觉得，好吧，就是这样。我搞砸了。这就是为什么我没拿到角色。对。而当你站在选角折叠床的另一边时，你，你真的很喜欢人们走进来，你立刻就知道他们是对的，或者他们不适合那个特定的角色。而且他们甚至还没开始读剧本。这甚至与才华无关。你甚至都没看到他们是否有才华。米奇，我记得当我们，你和我拍那部短命的节目《荒野求生》时，你在那个过程之前对我说，我们当时正在经历选角过程，你说，等着瞧吧，就像你刚才说的，等着看当你不在另一边时这个过程有多么不同，那是我第一次站在那个……嗯，折叠床的另一边。不，更像是一块跪垫。那是一块跪垫，因为，对。那是一个瑜伽球。为什么我一直在跪着？不管怎样，重点是这个，我以为你懂大概的意思，但，但你是对的。让我震惊的是，人们会走进来，我们认识的人或者我们共同认识的人会走进来，而且我们从来、从来、从来，当某人离开后，我们从来没有说过，那家伙太烂了。从来没有，从来没有，从来没有。
into an audition for the network. And I remember as a Monday morning I had flown out to LA and he goes, you're going to get this. So listen, I go, don't say that. Or are you crazy? Well, it's what I said after it that was really horrible that you didn't get. He should not get this. No, that I still wake up thinking about it. He came out. I was, I loved him immediately, just like I love Jason. You know, I just, you know, Will? Will cut came out from that audition and, or he, I guess you left first and then I stepped out of the room and I grabbed him and I said, you got it. You got it. They love you. And then I looked over to the left and there were two more guys waiting. And one of them was Rain. Wilson was a great, I mean, he ended up doing okay.
不，事实上，你太专注于，我是说，我不知道是不是每个人都这样，但我们绝对是。我是说，这可能归结于对演员的爱，但是，你知道，人们在向你展示某些东西。他们，他们，他们正在从心底向你展示一些东西，那是他们努力过的，其中也有需求。所以，你会非常强烈地感受到那个位置的特权。而且这是一种如此短暂的特权。所以你不会到处顶着这种感觉生活。但在那一刻，你确实有。而我一直以来最大的问题是，我在那些没有机会的人身上花了太多时间，因为我知道他们没有机会，而我想让他们有一个美好的体验。所以，是的，好吧，那是
Yeah. Had he gotten Job, he wouldn't have gotten the office and a longer run. Oh, the people that were there were all great, but they're, but you know how it is with casting. I often wish that actors could experience what it's like to be on the other side of that casting desk because, or in my case, couch or bed or it's a futon. We had a futon. We can't do that anymore. No more, no more, no more, no more. Well, you can with guys, right? Don't even joke about it. Oh, you can. No, you can't. Okay. And you can't even make jokes. Can I use sexist language? Yeah. If you, so you're saying if the actors could see the other side of the process, it would be less daunting? I imagine, I mean, you'd have to tell me, but I imagine for you guys early on in your career, these are all
你和你这个位置上其他人的区别，他们不那样处理，也不以那种方式对待其他人。这就是为什么每个人都喜欢你，你一直在工作，你很有才华，每个人都想和你继续合作，因为有些人对别人的感受缺乏尊重。肖恩，太棒了。你能，对不起，肖恩，我们重来一次。别那么，你知道我的意思吗？就是把你自己带入其中。好吧。我不知道你演的是个什么角色。好吧。我们还在，我们是停了还是继续？哦，就像，我又来了，对吧？我正做着呢，当我，谢谢。关于这个话题，说真的，而且我认为，我认为，我认为观众中的每个人，所有三个人都能感同身受，
fortunately, thankfully distant memories for you guys, but that, that there was a lot of preparation that went into auditions and then there was a lot of, you know, you're focused on yourself and a lot of self-examination and you get in there and you don't maybe do exactly what you'd planned and you feel like, well, there it is. I blew it. That's why I'm not getting it. Right. And when you're on the other side of that casting futon, you, you really like people come in and you immediately know that they're, they're right or they're not right for that particular character. And they haven't even started reading yet. And it's not about the talent. You haven't even seen if they're talented. Mitch, I remember when we, when you and I did this short lives show, Running
尽管他们可能不在这一行里，大概不在，大概对选角过程一点也不关心，但希望能对这个问题感同身受，那就是作为一个编剧，我想每个人都可以想象，他们，他们可能会写点东西，当你写东西的时候，你会想象房子会是什么样子，这个人会是什么样子，他们会如何说某句台词。你如何享受或不享受看着自己的想象力变成现实的过程，对于评估你所看到的是否有所不同或者是否是错的，你是多么公正？那是一个什么样的过程？太有趣了。这全都是，这全都是像，我可能在任何创作过程中，可能就像你们做的那样，这全都是控制与缺乏控制。你知道的，
Wild, and you said to me before that process, you were like, we were going through the casting process and you said, wait till you, exactly what you're saying, wait till you see how different this process is when you're not on the other side was the first time I'd ever had been on that side of the, um, futon. No, it was more like a kneeling rug. And it was a kneeling rug because, right. It was a yoga ball. Why was I kneeling all the time? Anyway, the point is this, I thought you got the general, but, but you're right. And what struck me was that people would come in and people that I knew or that we knew collectively would come in and it was, we never, ever, ever, when somebody left, we never once went, that guy sucked. Never, ever, never, ever.
这就像大脑的左右半球，因为你一直在进行剪辑，你在管理自己的期望，然后你也在努力放手并进入一种心流状态。对俺来说，它立刻就变成了我们的事，而不是我的事。所以，它在我的脑海里作为我的事存在了很长时间，也许，你知道，迈克尔·布鲁斯看起来像我父亲年轻时的样子，或者看起来像我弟弟什么的，而且听起来也像他。然后一旦换成了杰森，我大脑的另一部分就被真正激活了。现在我正在努力做，我觉得我是在努力给你们一些能让你们发光发热、发挥创造力并找到感觉的东西。我是说，这不是，这其实不是那么有意识的。只是觉得，
No, in fact, you're so focused on, I mean, I don't know that everybody's this way, but we certainly were. I mean, it's, it's maybe goes to the question of loving actors, but, you know, people are offering you something. They're, they're, they're offering you something from their heart and that they worked on and there's, there's need there too. So it's, it's, you, you so distinctly feel the privilege of that position. And it's such a temporary privilege. So it's not like you walk around feeling that way. But in that moment, you do. And the problem I've always had is I spend too long with the people who don't have a chance because I know they don't have a chance and I want them to have a good experience. So yeah, well, that's, that's the
拥有肖恩·海斯是多么疯狂的一件事，却不让他像我一样说话？你知道，相信我，我试过。没人喜欢这样。这并不像你想的那样普遍，常识会认为，既然它已经变得三维了，并且有了一个实际的面孔、声音和一切，你就会转变并能够适应这一点。我发现我工作中最不舒服的一些时刻是，当我觉得我正在从编剧或导演那里得到意见或指导时，是因为他们试图让你做他们一直想象的那样的事情，而不是对你带来的东西以及随之而来的观众将要接受的东西做出反应。
difference between you and other people in your position who don't approach it that way and don't approach treating other people that way. That's why everybody loves you and you work and you're talented and everybody wants to keep going with you because there are some people out there that don't have respect for feelings. Sean, that's great. Can you, I'm sorry, Sean, let's do that again. And just don't be, you know what I mean? Like just bring yourself to it. Okay. I don't know who this character is you're playing. Okay. Are we still, did we cut or are we still? Oh, like, I'm doing it again, aren't I? I'm doing it right now as I'm, thank you. On this subject and all seriousness, and I think, I think, I think everybody in the audience, all three of them can, can relate
但即便如此，这可能在试播集或电影中更为常见。是的。就像在电视里，很大程度上，当然是在喜剧中。在喜剧中，很大程度上是表演者和有时表演者与这个人的亲密感之间的即时性，因为你必须能够随时随地进入这种状态。我的意思是，我一直在转回肖恩身上，因为，你知道，他的角色和威尔的角色都是，他们都是比较宽泛的角色。然而你从你自己的身份中带来了一些真实的东西，这与杰克非常不同，也与乔布非常不同。好吧，杰克和乔布，我是说，我觉得我们可以出去把这个卖了。那是肯定的。刚刚发生了。
even though they might not be in the business, probably aren't, probably couldn't care less about the casting process, but could relate to this question, hopefully, which is you as a writer, I think everybody can imagine that they, that they would might write something and when you write something, you imagine what the house would look like, what the person would look like, how they would say a certain line. How do you enjoy or not enjoy the process of seeing your imagination come to life and, and how fair are you about assessing whether what you're seeing is different or is it wrong? What is that process? So interesting. It's all, it's all like, I probably in any creative process, probably what you guys do, it's all control and then lack of control. You know,
杰克和乔布。这是个节目还是？好吧，乔布和杰克，我们得让威尔加入。在冰上。抱歉，必须是威尔·阿奈特饰演乔布和杰克。我干这个。好吧，我觉得你只是其中一员。不，我是说威尔·阿奈特饰演乔布和杰克。那是，你知道的。顺便问一句，我在哪里签字？这听起来是个大买卖。
it's like, it's true left and right side of the brain because you're, you're kind of editing at all times, you're, you're managing your own expectations, and then you're also trying to let go and be in a flow. And for me, it immediately becomes our thing, not my thing. So it, so it, it lives as my thing in my head for a long time and maybe, you know, Michael Bluth looks like a young version of my father or looks like my brother or something and, and sounds like him. And then as soon as it's Jason, a different part of my brain is activated really. And now I'm trying to do, I feel like I'm trying to give you guys what will allow you to shine and will allow you to be creative and find it. I mean, it's not, it's not really that conscious. It's just that,
太棒了。这是少数几个双主角之一的角色，但你有点像个第三号配角。我认为这可能是一个很好的签约机会。真的只是退居二线。你有听这个播客吗？所以，等等，我想知道，你如此具有感染力地搞笑，如此具有感染力地温暖。我无法想象有人会和你合不来。在这期间，有没有遇到过某些性格很难搞的问题，你不得不弄清楚如何自己去应对，而你以前甚至不知道自己还有这样的一面？就像，哦，我从来没对付过这种人，所以我得在这方面做出转变。
like, how crazy would it be to have Sean Hayes and not, and try to get him to talk like me? You know, believe me, I've tried. Nobody likes it. It's not as common as you think where that what you would assume is common sense that, well, now that it's become three dimensional and there's actually a physical face and a sound and everything that you would pivot and be able to adapt to that. I've found that some of the more uncomfortable times that I've worked is when I feel like I'm getting a note or direction from a writer or director because they're trying to make you do what they have always imagined it to be, as opposed to reacting to what you're bringing to it and consequently what the audience is going to be
我无法想象你跟谁合不来。这就是我要说的。有几次，那是在早期，我正和一个演员在一个试播集里合作。天哪，我想说出他的名字。你简直不敢相信。我们送你半瓶啤酒。每个人都在说，哦天哪，这下难办了。你很难跟他相处。而我多少有点自负地觉得，不，我喜欢这家伙。我们会相处得很好的拍完那部试播集后，他们说，哇，那真的太好了。他好像很喜欢你。他朝上一个剧集运作人挥拳了。他朝他挥拳了。
receiving. But even that is probably more prevalent in pilots or in, maybe in films. Yeah. Like in television, so much of, it's certainly in comedy. In comedy, so much of it is, is the immediacy between the performer and the, sometimes the closeness of the performer to the person, because you just have to be able to access that all the time. I mean, I keep pivoting back to Sean because, you know, his character and Will's were both, they were both broad characters. And yet you brought something real from who you are, which is very different than Jack and very different than Job. Well, the Jack and Job, I mean, I think we could go out and sell that right. That's for sure. It's just happened.
对于事情能进展得如此顺利，我可能就不会那么轻率了。我记得早期和杰弗里·坦伯合作过，正如我们所知，关于杰弗里·坦伯我们听过很多传言，杰弗里其实是个温顺的小猫咪。他和任何人一样，容易情绪爆发。但从不，我是说，他从来没有虐待过任何人什么的。但是，你知道，他，他很吓人，因为他比我年长，而且他是，你知道的，喜剧之神之类的人物。我记得早期和他一起做过一个节目。那个想法是，这和我为肖恩考虑的是同一个。那是我父亲做过的一件事，他过去常常抱怨我弟弟的抱怨。你知道，迈克尔，我们得有个，我们得有个直率的，你知道，我们得做点什么，某个时候我们要把车开到桥上。然后我直接把钥匙拿走，把它扔进河里。我说，我不明白。
Jack and Job. Is this show or? Okay, Job and Jack, we had to get Will on board. On ice. Sorry, it would have to be Will Ornette as Job and Jack. I do that. Well, I think you're just one of the guys. No, I'm saying Will Ornette as Job and Jack. That's how, you know. By the way, where do I sign? That sounds like a great deal.
他说，好吧，你知道吗，我们去弄艘船。我们去达纳波特或者什么地方的海边。然后我们去到远远的湖心，我就把发动机推到海里去。我说，那，这能带来什么教训呢？他说，好吧，我喜欢他的回答，因为他说，好吧，我们总不能变成三具漂在船上的骷髅吧。我是说，总会发生点什么的。你知道的，我们总不能最后落得在这座桥上，车里有三具骷髅。
It's great. It's one of the few parts where it's a two-hander, but you kind of get to be a third banana. And I think that could be a great opportunity to sign. Really just step back. Have you listened to the podcast? So, wait, I want to know, you're so infectiously funny and infectiously warm. I can't imagine somebody not getting along with you. Has there been difficult issues with certain personalities along the way that you had to figure out how to navigate yourself that you didn't know there was a side of you? Like, oh, I've never dealt with this kind of person, so I'm going to have to shift in this way.
你知道，生活还要继续。你总能克服一些事情。所以我喜欢这个想法。车里坐着三具骷髅的想法。他们想不出该怎么办。所以，所以这个想法是，我把它写进了剧里，而这些男孩，你知道的，不是12岁和14岁。他们大约是25岁和28岁，他们在车里争吵。所以杰弗里·坦伯饰演的父亲把车挂进停车挡，拔下钥匙，
I can't imagine you not getting along with anybody. That's what I'm saying. There were a couple of times, it was early on where I was working with an actor on a pilot. God, I want to say his name. You can't believe it. We'll give you half a beer. And everybody kept saying, oh boy, this is going to be difficult. You're going to have a hard time with him. And I somewhat cockily sort of felt like, no, I like the guy. We'll get along great.
把它扔进河里，说道：真他妈的。我再也受不了这个了。我爱你们。你们得停止争吵了。然后有一些关于他们需要去其他地方但去不了的妙语，接着他就歇斯底里了。所以这只是一个小小的随性发挥，我想加进去。他很不高兴，然后把钥匙扔了。
And then after I was done shooting the pilot, they said, wow, that was really nice. He seemed to like you. He took a swing at the last showrunner. He took a swing at him. I might not have been so cavalier about the ease with which it was going to go down. I remember working early on with Jeffrey Tambor, and as we all know, a lot of what we've heard about Jeffrey Tambor, Jeffrey is a pussycat. And he, like anybody, is prone to emotional outbursts. But never, but I mean, he was never abusive or anything.
杰弗里开始演这场戏。你知道，他有时就这样，当他哭的时候，他的嘴会往下撇。他就像，我爱你们这些男孩。这真的很，你知道，就像，他在砸仪表盘。而且，但实际上情绪反应非常强烈。我是说，演员们，他们都在后座，因为我想某种程度上把他们 infantilize（当成小孩子）。他们在哭。所以有大约三个，车里没有骷髅。
But, you know, he would, he was scary because he was older than me and he was, you know, a comedy God and everything. And I remember doing a show early with him. And the idea was, this was the same one that I was thinking of Sean for. It was something my father had done where he used to complain about my brother's complaining. You know, Michael, we got a, we got a straight, you know, we got to do, let's get out on a bridge in the car at some point. And I'm just going to take the keys and I'll just, I'm just going to throw them out over into the river. I said, I don't understand.
有三个痛哭的男人，对吧？跟我想象的不同。但是，但是这场戏效果非常好。然后是一个更大的转折，正如你所想象的，当他在最后意识到，哦天哪，哦天哪，我做了什么？我做了什么？我得去那个什么地方。你妈妈在产房里。
He said, okay, you know what, we'll get a boat. We're going to go get a boat and we'll go off to the coast of Dana Point or something. Then we'll get way out there and I'll just push the engine into the ocean. I said, well, what, what lesson could possibly accrue from this? And he said, well, I loved his response because he said, well, we're not going to be three skeletons just floating in the boat. I mean, something's going to happen. You know, we're not going to be just to end up on this bridge, three skeletons in a car.
没错。就是那样。就像你妈妈和我女朋友在一起。所以在拍完之后，我就觉得，太棒了。当时跟我合作的托尼·托马斯，他是丹尼·托马斯的儿子，你知道的，他干这行很久了，他用手指捅了捅我的背说：去告诉他把情绪收一收。而我在跟三个明白这意味着什么的演员讲话。
You know, life goes on. You can always overcome something. And so I loved this idea. The idea of three skeletons sitting in a car. They couldn't figure out what to do. So, so the idea was, so I put that in a show and the boys, you know, is it, but they weren't 12 year olds and 14 year olds. They were like 25 year olds and 28 year olds and they're arguing in the car. And so Jeffrey Tamber is the father, throws the car into park and takes the key out and
我是说，你刚刚让一个真正袒露自己的演员情绪崩溃。我是说，你不能，你不能就这样收回来。你不能就这样，而且，而且，我当然不想处于去训斥一个刚刚以那种方式敞开心扉的人的位置。是的。所以，我，这就是一个例子，好吧，我得想个办法去奉承他，这样当我真正去给意见时，它是可以接受的。除此之外，那一个是给你的。
throws it into the river and says, God damn it. I'm not going to put up with this anymore. I love you guys. You're going to stop fighting. And then there was some punchline about something else they needed to get to and they couldn't get to it and then he got hysterical. So it was just a little throwaway thing I wanted to get. He gets upset and he throws the keys.
我们，好吧，我们有一个那样的。我们拿下了。那你说了什么？你说了什么？你是怎么把双手放进笼子里的？所以我，你知道的，他那时候体型很大，你知道，他大概300磅重，而且他就像个大泰迪熊，你知道的，但即便如此，我还是个这行的新手。所以我不得不走过去，我记得我在那儿站了一会儿，他说：
And Jeffrey starts playing the scene. You know, he does that sometimes when he's crying, his mouth goes down. And he's like, I love you boys. And it's really, you know, like, and he's pounding on the dashboard. And, and, but it actually having a very emotional reaction. I mean, the actors, they're both in the back seat because I wanted to kind of infantilize them. They're crying. So there's like three, there's no skeletons in the car.
啊，那个有什么问题？那个有什么问题？而且，其他演员也没有帮忙，因为他们说：哦天哪，那是我在喜剧中拍过最不可思议的一场戏。太不可思议了。我说，哦，就是那条。就是那个。我们搞定了。
There's three weeping men, right? Different than I imagined. But, but it's, it's the scene is working great. And, and then a much bigger turn as you can imagine when he realizes at the end, oh God, oh God, what have I done? What have I done? I got to get to the whatever. Your mother's in the delivery room.
我们搞定了。哇。完成了。拍完了。然后我尽可能久地停顿了一下，我说：嘿，要不我们为了好玩，稍微轻松一点再拍一条？他咬牙切齿，在片场气冲冲地走来走去。我当时想：我不知道该怎么办。
Exactly. That's what it was. It was like your mother and my girlfriend are together. So after the thing, I was like, that was great. And Tony Thomas, who I worked for at the time, who's Danny Thomas' son and, you know, he's been doing this for a long time, sticks his finger into my back and says, go tell him to bring it down. And I'm talking to three actors who understand what that means.
我一动不动地站着，我能感觉到他只是感到尴尬和沮丧，你知道的，气冲冲地走来走去，气冲冲地走来走去。然后我到了，我是说，他没有对我大喊大叫什么的，但你能看出他真的很火大。所以我只是僵在原地。然后当他终于走到我站的地方附近时，我说，我感觉他开始觉得，我可能需要一个台阶下。
I mean, you've just got an actor who's really exposed himself. I mean, you can't, you can't just pull that back. You can't just, and, and, and I certainly don't want to be in a position of scolding somebody who's just opened themselves up in that way. Yeah. So I, that was an example of like, all right, I'm going to have to find a way to supplicate such that when I do get around to giving the note, it's, it's acceptable. And I, other than that one was for you.
所以我说：我只是想调一下层次感。他说：哦，调层次感。靠。行。我们来。我一整天都可以这么干。我会调层次感。我很乐意调层次感。是的。
We, okay, we have one that way. We've got that. So what'd you say? What'd you say? How'd you put your hands in the cage? So I, and, you know, he was big at that time, you know, he's like 300 pounds and he's a teddy bear, you know, but still I was brand new at this. So I had to walk out there and I remember I stood there for a while and he said,
他的幽默感和存在感是如此，是如此有趣。我记得在《发展受阻》的第一天，我是《拉里·桑德斯秀》的超级粉丝，我走向他，我对他说：坦伯先生，杰弗里，叫我杰弗里就行。我太高兴我们能一起合作了。我真的很期待今天的这场戏，祝你今天过得愉快。是的。
ah, what's wrong with that? What's wrong with that? And, and the other actors were not helping because they were saying like, oh my God, that was the most incredible scene I've ever done in a comedy. That was incredible. And I said, oh, that was the one. That was it. We got it.
他看着我说道：少他妈的教我做事。我知道这是一种幽默感。是的。那个冷幽默，把我笑死了。是的。我太喜欢了。我笑得前仰后合。我读过剧本围读会，
We got it. Wow. It's done. It's in the can. And then I took as long a pause as I possibly could and I said, hey, why don't we do one just a little lighter just for fun? And he said his teeth and he went stomping around the set. And I was like, I don't know what to do.
杰森，我想那是很多很多年以前和你一起的。我想那是和你一起。那是一部电影，那是一场很大的围读会。也许是他的姐姐。可能是我姐姐。也许是他的姐姐，贾斯汀。有可能。我和杰弗里同时到达了门框边。我从没真正见过他。
I stood perfectly still and I could, he was just embarrassed and upset and, you know, like stomping around and stomping around. And then I got to, I mean, he wasn't, he didn't yell at me or anything, but he just, you could tell he was really pissed off. So I just sort of froze in place. And then when he finally kind of came back to where I was standing, I said, it looks like I got the sense that he started to feel like, I might need a way out of this.
那是我们第一次见面。同时到达门口。他说：哦，请吧，按演员表排名前后。然后他让我先走。哇。我记得，我记得就像第一季的时候我们在拍什么东西，然后不知什么原因，他把电话号码给了我，
So I said, I just meant to play with the levels. And he said, oh, play with the levels. Shit. Yeah. We'll do that. I'll do that all day long. And I'll play with the levels. I'm happy to play with the levels. Yeah.
我记下了，然后他说：拿到我的电话号码你有多高兴？他真逗，从不眨眼。是的。太棒了。回到节目上来。米奇，米奇，米奇，如果可以的话，带大家了解一下。
His humor, his humor and presence was so, was so interesting. I remember the first day on, on arrested when I, I was such a huge fan from the Larry Sanders show and, and I walked up to him and I said, Mr. Tamber, Jeffrey, Jeffrey's fine. I just so excited that we're doing this together. And I just really looking forward to the scene today and, and just, I guess, just have a great day. Yeah.
有几件事我想聊聊。你谈到为托尼·托马斯工作。你最先在《黄金女郎》工作。是这样吗？是的。好吧，我当时是个跑腿的。我们得聊聊这个。我是说，这是我最喜欢的节目之一。这是一部伟大的剧。
And he looked at me and he said, don't you fucking tell me what to do. I know it's a sense of humor. Yeah. That drag, it killed me. Yeah. I loved it. I laughed my ass off. I did a table read. I, Jason, I think with you many, many years ago.
为了肖恩的姐姐，跑腿的到底是做什么的？你知道的，这真的是一个相当吃力不讨好的工作，就像每个人一样。简单描述一下就好，因为我想聊聊《黄金女郎》。好吧。是的。跑腿的到底是做什么的？当娱乐业刚开始的时候，我是说，
And I think it was with you. It was a movie and it was a, it was a big table read. Maybe he's his sister. It could have been my sister. Maybe it was his sister, Justine. It might have been. And me and Jeffrey got to the door jam at the exact same time. And I never really met him.
而且我想那次是在你那里。那是一部电影，是一次很大规模的剧本围读。也许那是他的姐姐。也可能是我的姐姐。也许那是他的姐姐，贾斯汀。很有可能。我和杰弗里在同一时刻到达了门框那里。我以前其实从来没见过他。
That's the first time I met him. And got to the door at the exact same time. And he goes, oh, please, in order of billing. And he had me go first. Wow. I remember, I remember like the first season we were doing something and then I ended up, for some reason, he gave me his phone number
那是我们第一次见面。我们同时到了门口，他说，哦，请吧，按出场顺序来。然后让我先进去了。哇。我记得，我记得就像第一季的时候我们在拍什么东西，然后最后，不知为什么，他把他的电话号码给了我
and I took it down and then he said, how happy are you to get my phone number? He's funny, man. Never winks. Yeah. That's so good. All right. Back to the show. Mitch, Mitch, Mitch, take everybody if you can.
我把它记下来了，然后他说，拿到我的电话号码你有多高兴？他真逗，从不眨眼。太棒了。好了，回到节目中。米奇，米奇，米奇，如果可以的话，带大家了解一下。
A couple of things I want to talk about. You talked about working for Tony Thomas. You, you worked first at Golden Girls. Is that right? Yes. Well, I was a runner. We got to talk about that. I mean, it's one of my favorite shows ever. It's one of the great shows.
我想聊几件事。你提到了为托尼·托马斯工作。你，你最初是在《黄金女郎》工作。是这样的吗？是的。嗯，我当时是个杂务。我们得聊聊这个。我的意思是，这是我最喜欢的节目之一。这是一部伟大的节目。
For Sean's sister, what does a runner do? You know, it's, it really is a fairly thankless, and like everybody. Just a short description because I want to get to the Golden Girls. Okay. Yeah. Just what does a runner do? When entertainment began, and I mean,
对于肖恩的姐姐来说，跑腿人员（runner）是做什么的？你知道的，这真的是一项相当吃力不讨好的工作，就像每个人一样。简单描述一下就好，因为我想聊聊《黄金女郎》。好的。是的。跑腿人员到底是做什么的？当娱乐业刚起步时，我的意思是，
I love this concept of one human being reaching out to another. All right. All right, all right. I'm trying to go quick, Sean, but I just got to give it the context. The Lumiere Brothers. Okay. So, so runner, a runner basically is,
我喜欢这种人与人之间敞开心扉的概念。好吧。好吧，好吧。肖恩，我想快点，但我必须交代一下背景。卢米埃尔兄弟。好吧。所以，所以跑腿，跑腿基本上是，
it's, it's at the entry level job on these shows, as you guys know, but I guess you're pretending you don't. And, and you, you know, use Xerox scripts and you, you deliver coffee. And I remember thinking there must be, this is a mistake. This cannot be what, you know, as I'd given people spec scripts and I'd,
这是这些剧组里最基层的职位，如你们所知，不过我猜你们在假装不知道。然后，你，你知道的，去复印剧本，然后送咖啡。我当时心想，这肯定不对，这一定是个错误。这绝对不可能是，你知道的，因为我曾经给过别人剧本大纲，而且我还，
I'd given a resume that I think even had some student body positions on there. Sure. I was padding a little bit. I see you were a treasurer at Estancia High School. Yes. Matter of fact, I learned a lot about responsibility. So, but suddenly I'm, I'm, you know, delivering coffee and I wasn't even,
我交过简历，上面好像还写过一些学生会职务。好吧，我是稍微润色了一下。我看到你曾担任斯坦西亚高中的财务。是的。事实上，我学到了很多关于责任的知识。所以，但突然之间，我，我，你知道的，开始送咖啡了，而且我甚至不，
like at the time I remember I had to go drive to Venice from Hollywood to pick up coffee at the Rose Cafe. And then I'd drive it all the way across town back to Hollywood. And then I'd hand it to the runner coordinator and he would walk the six steps into Tony Thomas' office and Paul Whit's office
就像当时我记得我得从好莱坞开车到威尼斯海滩的罗丝咖啡馆去买咖啡。然后我得一路把车开回好莱坞。然后把咖啡交给我跑腿协调员，他会走那六步路走进托尼·托马斯办公室和保罗·惠特的办公室，
and say, here's your coffee. Let me know if there's any problem. And I'll be happy to send somebody out and get some new coffee. And I remember thinking like, I'm screwed. I'm never, I'll be a skeleton. And then the runner from that time. Wait, Mitch, Mitch, at the time,
然后说，这是您的咖啡。如果有任何问题请告诉我。我很乐意派人出去买新的咖啡。我当时心想，我完蛋了。我永远，我都要化成白骨了。然后当时那个跑腿的。等等，米奇，米奇，当时，
were you wearing, were you wearing a sport coat? Yes. Yes. So my father. You knew I was going to ask this. Yeah. That's, that was another good little piece of advice my father gave me because he, we were, he was very fit and I was a young guy. And so we were the same size sport coat. And he was a lawyer.
你穿着，你穿着运动西装吗？是的。是的。所以我的父亲。你知道我要问这个。对。那是，那是家父给我的另一个好建议，因为他，我们，他身体非常好，而我还是个年轻人。所以我们穿同一尺码的运动西装。而且他是个律师。
So we had all these like suits and sport coats. And so I would just borrow them. I just take them. And it was his suggestion. He said, you know, you want to create a mismatch. He knew David Geffen a little. And he always said, you know, David Geffen came along at a time when all the managers and agents
所以我们有所有这些西装和运动西装。所以我就会借来穿。我直接拿来穿。这是他的建议。他说，你知道，你要制造一种反差。他稍微认识大卫·格芬。他总是说，你知道大卫·格芬崛起的时候，所有的经理人和经纪人，
were dressing in three piece suits. And he came along and he was like an artist, even though he was the most killer businessman of them all. And, you know, at that time, everyone was wearing, it was kind of grunge was in and it was like torn t-shirts and stuff. And I was there somehow the audacity to wear a sport coat every day.
都穿着三件套西装。而他出现时就像个艺术家，尽管他是所有人中最厉害的商业巨头。而且，你知道，当时每个人都在穿，有点像垃圾摇滚正流行，穿得破破烂烂的T恤之类的。而我却不知哪里来的厚脸皮，每天都穿运动西装。
And it worked. It worked at Paul Witt about, you know, like maybe two months into a job that should have taken years said, you know, we've had our eye on you. Something about you. And I was like, I wonder what, I wonder what it is. This was Golden Girls.
而且这招管用了。在保罗·惠特那里管用了，大概，你知道的，在入职大约两个月后——本该花好几年时间的职位——他说，你知道的，我们一直在关注你。你身上有些特质。我当时心想，我在想是什么，我在想那是什么。这是《黄金女郎》。
You were a runner on Golden Girls. And didn't you end up being one of the head writers? If not the head writers. Yeah, I was especially right at the very end for the, the spin-off they did called the Golden Palace. So then how many years did that cover from, from entry level position to basically the boss? It was fairly quick for me.
你是《黄金女郎》的跑腿。而且你最后不是成了首席编剧之一吗？如果不是首席编剧的话。对，我特别在他们制作的那部衍生剧《黄金宫殿》的最后阶段担任了编剧。那么从基层职位到基本上成为老板，这涵盖了多少年？对我来说挺快的。
It felt long. Five years, six, 12? Well, I did. Then I became a development executive. And that was fairly brutal for me because I was, I had been a comedy writer in high school. You know, I read the high school plays and I just, I always loved comedy.
感觉挺久。五年，六年，十二年？好吧，我做过。后来我成了发展主管。对我来说那相当残酷，因为我，我在高中时就当过喜剧编剧。你知道的，我读过高中的戏剧，我一直都很热爱喜剧。
And now I was reading, you know, really, at that time very hacky sitcom scripts because sitcoms were really hacky. Yeah. And I just was going down this executive path. So that was the downside of wearing the sport coat. It was like, this guy's got executive material. Did you end up writing a spec for Golden Girls?
而现在我在读，你知道的，真的很——当时非常平庸的的情景喜剧剧本，因为情景喜剧真的很平庸。对。而我当时正朝着这条行政主管的道路走下去。所以这就是穿运动西装的负面影响。感觉就像，这家伙有高管的潜质。你最后有没有为《黄金女郎》写过试播集剧本？
How did that happen that you made that leap? I, I think I wrote, I wrote a spec. Yeah. So a spec script is like a sample script. And I had written a couple others. And so I wrote one for a show called Empty Nest before it was a show. It was just a pilot.
你是怎么做到跨出那一步的？我，我想我写过，我写过试播集剧本。对。所以试播集剧本就像是一个样品剧本。我还写过其他几个。所以我为一部叫《空巢》的剧写过一个，在它成为正式剧集之前。它当时只是个试播集。
And, and that got their attention. And, and they just, I don't know, I, who cares? I think it's interesting. We do, we care. How many, I mean, I'm a huge fan of the show. So I think it's fascinating. How many years did you write on the show? So I think I was a writer like in full for the show
然后，那引起了他们的注意，然后他们就，我不知道，谁在乎呢？我觉得这很有趣。我们会的，我们在乎。你写了多少，我是说，我是这部剧的超级粉丝。所以我认为这太迷人了。你为这部剧写了多少年？所以我想我正式为这部剧担任编剧，
for the last maybe three years of it. And did you ever get, did you get to know the actors? Oh yes, very well. Yeah. And isn't it true that Estelle Getty, wasn't she the youngest out of them? She, I don't think she was the youngest. I think Ru was, but she was young.
大概是它最后的三年的时间。你有没有，你有机会认识演员吗？哦，是的，非常熟。对。而且是不是真的，埃丝特·盖蒂，她不是她们当中年纪最小的吗？她，我不认为她是年纪最小的。我想鲁思是的，但她确实很年轻。
She was probably 67 and I think- Playing the oldest one. I think Ru was 57. Oh wow. Wow. Yeah. Wow. Yeah, it was just so funny and clever
她大概67岁，而且我觉得——却在演最老的那一个。我想鲁思是57岁。哦，哇。哇。对。哇。是的，真的太有趣、太聪明了，
and we'd never seen anything like it. And of course the writing was brilliant. Golden Girls, the jokes, well the jokes were so good. There were so many jokes. There was so many training joke writing and it was, and they could make anything work. And, and I loved Bea. I had a great relationship with Bea.
我们从未见过这样的作品。当然剧本写得太棒了。《黄金女郎》，那些笑话，嗯，笑话太精彩了。有太多的笑话了。有大量密集的笑话创作，而且，她们能让任何东西都行得通。而且，我爱碧。我和碧的关系非常好。
People were kind of scared of Bea, but I, but she was, you know, it's, it's, this comment has been made before, but she was kind of- Mr. Arthur. Tough on the outside and soft on the inside. And, and Betty was, you know, sort of softer on the outside. And am I saying this backwards? No, no, you got it.
人们有点怕碧，但是，但是她，你知道的，这，这，这个评价以前也被做过，但她有点——亚瑟女士。外表坚强，内心柔软。而且，贝蒂，你知道的，算是外表柔软。我是不是说反了？不，不，你没说错。
They both had soft internal organs. Their internal organs were- Those are medical conditions, Miss. Those are- They're medical conditions. And because of that dynamic between the two, did they, did they work together well? Did they collaborate?
她们两人的内心器官都很柔软。她们的内部器官是——那是医疗状况，小姐。那是——那是医疗状况。正因为她们两人的这种动态关系，她们，她们合作得好吗？她们有默契地合作吗？
Say whatever you want. It felt like a really good creative collaboration. You know, it was kind of like, there are often those things like, you know, John Lennon and Paul McCartney, where there's one that's a little harder and one that's a little softer, kind of a matriarch and a patriarch and,
你想怎么说都行。感觉就像是一次非常棒的创意合作。你知道，有点像，经常会有那种情况，你知道的，约翰·列侬和保罗·麦卡特尼，其中一个稍微强硬一点，另一个稍微温和一点，有点像女家长和男家长，
and that, that kind of played out with them. But they were, they were really special. And, and my stuff, you know, it's been said before that like your style is formed by what you can't do. And sometimes it's by what you think you can't do. And when I started off there, I remember thinking, well, you know, these are experienced joke writers. I don't know how to write jokes.
然后，这种关系在她们身上也有所体现。但她们真的非常特别。而且，我的东西，你知道的，以前有人说过，你的风格是由你做不到的事情塑造的。有时是由你以为自己做不到的事情塑造的。当我刚开始在那儿的时候，我记得自己心想，好吧，你知道的，这些都是经验丰富的笑话写手。我不知道怎么写笑话。
I mean, I loved comedy and I loved things that were funny, but I didn't know how to write that, you know, eight word joke that, and that show was, you know, it's what we kind of emulated with the rest. And certainly, Will and Grace had this as well, you know, where it's like the setup is funny, the punchline is funny, the line after it is funny, the callback to the setup is funny,
我是说，我喜欢喜剧，我喜欢搞笑的事情，但我不知道怎么写那种八个字的笑话，而那部剧就是，你知道的，我们对其他作品所效仿的典范。当然，《威尔与格蕾丝》也是这样，你知道的，设置很搞笑，包袱很搞笑，后面的台词很搞笑，对前面设置的回扣很搞笑，
the incidental line that somebody throws in is funny. And so it was really tough training that way. But all my stuff kind of became story because I think I felt like I couldn't write those hard jokes. I started, my stories were just really intricate and layered so that something would come up four times. Oh, so today's different. Kind of cummer.
别人顺口抛出的一句闲话也很搞笑。所以那样的训练真的很难。但我所有的东西都变成了故事，因为我觉得我写不出那种硬核笑话。我开始的时候，我的故事非常错综复杂、充满层次，以至于一个梗会出现四次。哦，所以现在不同了。有点像……
There's a little, you just took a break from that kind of story telling today. Yeah, but Mitch. Now I'm just a ratatatter. Kind of to that, to that idea that it became about story. I think that one of the things that, you know, you can go back and watch shows that were big hits in the 90s or early 2000s,
今天你只是从那种讲故事的方式中休息了一下。对，但米奇。现在我只是个连珠炮了。顺着那个，那个故事性的思路，我认为其中一件事，你知道的，你可以回过头去看看90年代或2000年代初大获成功的剧集，
legitimately great big shows that were funny at the time, that when you watch them now, they were so, I don't know, the jokes just seem to... Written, probably. Well, no, it's more that they're just two of the times. So they don't... Oh, I see, they're topical, you mean? Yeah, and then they just don't translate to today.
确实很棒的大制作剧集，当时觉得很好笑，但现在回看时，它们太，我不知道，那些笑话看起来只是……大概是写出来的吧。哦，不，更像是它们带有时代的局限性。所以它们不……哦，我明白了，你是说它们很应景？对，然后它们就无法传达到今天。
So you have, but what you've always maintained, and I remember, I don't know if you remember this, but I've learned so many great lessons from you, and one of them was that always be... I remember we were writing something, you mean Jimmy, in that very room that in which you're sitting right now. Yeah, right where I'm sitting, yeah.
所以你有，但你一直坚持的，我记得，我不知道你还记不记得，我从你身上学到了很多伟大的经验，其中之一就是永远要……我记得我们在写什么东西时，你是说吉米，就在你现在坐着的那个房间里。对，就坐在我坐的这个地方，对。
And Mitch, you'd be sitting there at the computer, and we'd be pitching jokes. Jimmy Valli, great Jimmy Valli, and hilarious old friend of Mitch's, and partner in writing pal and just everything. And we would be pitching jokes, and you'd go, and even to your own jokes, like just the three of us just talking,
米奇，你会坐在那里对着电脑，我们在抛出笑话。吉米·瓦利，伟大的吉米·瓦利，米奇搞笑的老朋友，写作伙伴兼一切。我们会抛出笑话，然后你就会说，甚至对你自己的笑话也是如此，就像我们三个在聊天，
and you'd go, we'd laugh, and laugh, and laugh, and then you'd stop, and you'd go, yeah, but it's just, it's not telling the story. And you'd put it off to the side, you might put it in another folder, but you're like, we can't use that joke, even though it's the best joke that we had heard in the last three hours.
然后你会说，我们笑啊，笑啊，笑啊，然后你停下来，说，好吧，但它只是，它并没有在讲故事。然后你会把它放在一边，可能会把它放到另一个文件夹里，但你会说，我们不能用那个笑话，尽管这是我们在过去三个小时里听过的最好的笑话。
Yeah, and even though a lot of those jokes, you know, ended up in other pilots I did that you guys never found out about, but what I was trying to teach you was... But you know what I mean? Like that was... No, but it's true. I do think that everything is story in a way, and everything that, you know,
对，尽管其中很多笑话，你知道的，最后用在了我做的其他试播集里，你们从来没发现过，但我当时想教你们的是……但你知道我的意思吗？就像那是……不，但这是真的。我确实认为一切在某种程度上都是故事，而且一切，你知道的，
every laugh that you guys have ever gotten, I mean, there are ways to be funny. You can, there are family guy things where they're just non sequiturs that are funny, but you know, it's just much funnier to, you know, for instance, for Sean to find out that what his mother was betting on at the supermarket were the fiberglass horses.
你们听过的每一个笑头，我是说，搞笑有很多种方式。你可以，有《居家男人》那种无厘头的好笑，但你知道的，相比之下，比方说，让肖恩发现他母亲在超市押注的是玻璃纤维马，要有趣得多。
That's story. But there is something to, like, there's a non sequitur, there's, you know, and then there's like, but this is about a character, and it's why, I mean, it's... Wait, no, Mitch, let me ask you something. We always ask people like, what were your comedy influences when you grew up, but are there comedy people that you're drawn to today
那是故事。但确实有某种东西，比如，有无厘头的，有，你知道的，然后还有，但这是关于一个角色的，这也是为什么，我是说，这是……等等，不，米奇，让我问你个问题。我们总是问别人，你成长过程中的喜剧影响是什么，但现在有没有什么喜剧人吸引你，
that what are you, like, what do you, who do you admire now? Who's out there now that you're like, wow, I would love to write like that, or I'd love to meet that person because they're a great stand-up or I like their show or something in the comedy world? You know, I always just like funny people. I don't even have a good answer for that.
你是怎么看的，比如，你现在崇拜谁？现在外面有谁让你觉得，哇，我真想那样写作，或者我很想见见那个人，因为他们是个很棒的单口喜剧演员，或者我喜欢他们的节目，或者喜剧界的某个人？你知道的，我总是喜欢有趣的人。我甚至给不出一个好答案。
I mean, there are people that I just find, and oftentimes it's people who can completely consume the character or subsume, or just be the character, I guess, is what I'm getting at. And it's why I always loved about what Jason does, that, you know, Jason played a character who was ostensibly a straight man on Arrested Development, but he was so much more.
我是说，有些人的表演能让我，而且通常是那些能完全融入角色，或者将自我融于角色，或者干脆就是那个角色的人，我想这就是我想表达的。这也是为什么我一直很喜欢杰森的表现，你知道的，杰森在《发展受阻》中扮演了一个表面上看起来是白脸的角色，但他远不止于此。
He had so many flaws, and Jason was able to play him with all his blind spots and what he doesn't see about himself. And, you know, I think of like just other contemporary, funny people. Will and I were talking about Fred Armisen the other day, and Fred is so funny because he, again, it's like he just becomes this character.
他有那么多的缺点，而杰森能够把这个角色身上所有的盲点以及他对自己的视而不见都演出来。而且，你知道，我想到了其他当代有趣的人。我和威尔前几天还在聊弗莱德·阿米森，弗莱德是那么搞笑，因为他，同样地，就像他直接变成了这个角色。
And that's kind of a faction of story in a way. Do you see that what the public considers funny changing noticeably in the last year, in the last five years? And if so, has it affected the way you approach sort of breaking a story or a concept of premise for something funny? I feel like comedy has gotten less important out there. I don't know if you guys are...
在某种程度上，这也是故事的一个派生。你觉得公众认为好笑的东西在过去的一年、过去的五年里发生了明显的改变吗？如果是这样，它是否影响了你构思故事或喜剧前提的方式？我觉得喜剧在现在的分量变得没那么重要了。我不知道你们是不是……
Meaning it's sillier or it's broader now? No, that there's not as much of it. People don't need it. There's no comedy features. There's no comedy. I know. I think it's because there's been this big international movement and comedy typically doesn't work internationally.
意思是它更幼稚了还是更低俗了？不，是它的数量没那么多了。人们不需要它了。没有什么喜剧长片了。没有喜剧了。我知道。我想这是因为经历了一场巨大的国际化运动，而喜剧通常在国际上行不通。
I mean, in fact, we know that it does, but that people are always scared of it. And nobody... Well, here's Mitch, just to give it some context, which Mitch is kind of referring to, and certainly some of our friends even at Netflix will admit that, you know, you'd start to go in and pitch them shows
我是说，事实上，我们知道它是行的通的，但人们总是对此感到害怕。而且没有人……好吧，米奇，为了给你提供一些背景，米奇所指的这种现象，当然我们在网飞的一些朋友也会承认，你知道的，你过去常常去向他们推销节目，
over the last couple of years, and they're like, well, we need that show to resonate globally, and we think that those jokes globally. So those jokes about the guy who... We had a show, this jokes about the guy who works in Utah at this thing, those aren't really going to translate. And it's like, the fuck are you talking about?
在过去的几年里，他们会说，我们需要这个节目能在全球引起共鸣，而我们认为这些笑话在全球。所以那些关于那个家伙的笑话——我们有个节目，这些笑话是关于在犹他州做这个的那个家伙的——那些真的无法跨文化传达。然后就像，你们他妈在说什么？
These are jokes. Jokes are jokes or jokes. Because comedy has to be specific, and it has to be really... It has to be. Yeah, but if it's reliant on something that is only known to the domestic audience, it won't travel,
这些是笑话。笑话就是笑话。因为喜剧必须具体，而且必须非常……必须是这样。是的，但如果它依赖于只有本土观众才知道的东西，它就无法传播，
and therefore they won't spend as much or anything else. Perhaps. I don't mean to call it Netflix. I mean, just everybody. I mean, that's an example. But I mean that that, unfortunately, is kind of what Mitch was saying, that there is this idea that...
因此他们就不会花那么多钱或做其他事情。也许吧。我不是特指网飞。我是说，所有人。我的意思是，这是一个例子。但我的意思是，不幸的是，这正是米奇所说的，存在这样一种观念，即……
Right, it used to be... It's almost like sitcoms got less funny for a while, because they were trying to appeal to so many people. They were... It was the lowest common denominator. Right, yeah. But don't you think back to what you said about... It seems like people care about comedy so much.
对，过去……这几乎就像情景喜剧有一段时间变得不那么好笑了，因为它们试图迎合太多的人。它们是……那是最低俗的迎合。对，没错。但你不觉得回想一下你刚才说的话……看起来人们非常在乎喜剧。
Don't you think, well, a large part of it is due to the pandemic. Sure, it was a little bit before that, but don't you think it's about to turn? Don't you think about... Don't you think people are looking for joy and laughter and anything other than just doom? Yeah.
难道你不觉得，很大一部分原因是因为大流行。当然，在那之前就有一点苗头了，但你不觉得它快要转运了吗？难道你不觉得……难道你不觉得人们在寻找欢乐、笑声以及除了末日绝望之外的一切吗？对。
I'll bet it's coming. I know they are. Well, disagree. I disagree. I know that people are looking for it. I don't know that the broadcasters are looking for it, because it went from lowest common denominator to being really specific
我敢说它快来了。我知道它们会的。好吧，我不同意。我不同意。我知道人们在寻找它。我不知道广播公司是否在寻找它，因为当网飞这些平台刚起步时，它从最低俗的迎合变成了非常具体的东西，
when Netflix and these places started out, and you could do these subgenres and these little interesting looks at lifestyles. And then now it has become... It seems really big. Even a show like Ted Lasso, which has a lot of laughs and everything, is really clearly designed and does it very effectively.
你可以做那些垂直细分类型和对生活方式的有趣观察。然后现在它已经变成了……看起来体量变得很大。即使像《足球教练》这样有很多笑声和一切的剧，也显然是经过精心设计并且非常有效地做到了这一点。
Have you seen Chad? To reach a lot of people. I saw an early version of Chad, which is great. So freaking funny. I know, really. Nassim Pedrad is from Center Night Live. Yeah. She plays a teenage boy,
你看过《查德》吗？为了触达大量观众。我看过《查德》的早期版本，太棒了。超级搞笑。我知道，真的。娜西姆·佩德拉德是《周六夜现场》出来的。对。她扮演一个十几岁的男孩，
and it's the funniest thing I've ever... It's hilarious. And it's taken them maybe five or six years to get that show made, because that pilot had been made four or five years ago. And do you think that they probably predetermined, well, we're only really our ambition for sort of audience size is only going to be X,
这是我见过的最搞笑的东西……太爆笑了。而且他们花了差不多五六年才把那个节目做出来，因为那个试播集在四五年前就拍好了。你觉得他们是不是预先决定好了，好吧，我们对观众规模的野心其实也就是X，
and therefore we'll price it accordingly, and let's just do it? Well, I think that... The pricing is part of the problem. I think things got really expensive. You know, when we did Arrested, we did it very inexpensively. And I remember...
因此我们会做相应的定价，然后就这样干吧？嗯，我觉得……定价是问题的一部分。我觉得制作成本变得非常昂贵。你知道，我们拍《发展受阻》时，成本非常低。而且我记得……
I mean, we probably did it... Now, these numbers are huge by normal standards, but it was something probably like a million six or something to make an episode. Wow. And then right when we got done, I did a pilot at Sony, and it was like $4,500,000.
我是说，我们拍的时候可能……按标准来看，这些数字对正常标准来说很大，但拍一集大概也就一百六十万左右。哇。然后我们刚一拍完，我在索尼做了一个试播集，花了一千四百五十万美元。
For a half hour? Yeah, for a half hour. For episode? Yeah, and we didn't go. I mean, it was just too expensive for... So that's been part of the problem. Well, would you rather... I don't know the answer.
就半小时的剧？对，就半小时。一集？对，而且我们没能续订。我是说，对于……来说太贵了。所以这也是问题的一部分。好吧，你宁愿……我不知道答案。
Would you rather do something that is tonally specific, but for a lesser price than something that would give you a big check but reach a gazillion people? I kind of think the big check is not even in the offing right now. Right. What if you were like only the big check?
你宁愿做一个调性具体但成本较低的项目，还是做一个能拿到巨额支票但能触达无数人的项目？我感觉巨额支票现在根本没戏。对。如果你只能选巨额支票呢？
Yeah, oh, I would... Yeah, if there was... By the way, that would be choice one. Yeah, okay, so... Okay, choice one, only the big check, no show. I don't have to do anything. That's great. Choice two, big check,
对，哦，我会……对，如果有的话……顺便说一句，那会是首选。对，好吧……好吧，首选，只要巨额支票，不要剧。我什么都不用做。那太棒了。第二选择，巨额支票，
easiest show I could possibly do. Do you think they'd make a rest of development today? I don't think so. I think it was... I mean, it was barely made when we made it. That's true. And it was because it was right at a cuss period where they were still going for the big audience.
我能做的最简单的剧。你觉得他们今天还会拍《发展受阻》吗？我不觉得。我觉得它当时……我是说，我们拍的时候它就差点没拍成。确实如此。而且那是因为它正好处于一个他们还在追求大受众的过渡期。
I don't know how we got that on the air. It was really just the will of the people that liked it at the networking at the studio. And do you think that these sort of un-PC moments of humor in it would even be tolerated even by a niche audience today? No. That could be one of the reasons the comedy is challenged right now.
我不知道我们是怎么把它搬上电视的。真的只是因为网络和制片厂里那些喜欢它的人的意愿。你觉得今天哪怕是在一个小众观众群体中，剧中那些政治不正确的幽默时刻还能被容忍吗？不能。这可能是喜剧现在面临挑战的原因之一。
Yeah. That people are... I don't think it's necessarily wrong. I mean, there have been a lot of people have taken it on the chin for a long time and there isn't an appetite for making fun of people. But of course, comedy is just making fun of individuals, not making fun of groups.
对。人们……我不认为这一定是错的。我是说，很多人长期以来一直承受着重压，现在大家没有那种取笑别人的胃口了。但当然，喜剧只是取笑个人，而不是取笑群体。
And what you guys did on the show was always make fun of yourself. That's what I was talking about with blind spots. And Joe being full of bravado, but then in a moment later, just being completely fragile and devastated by some insult from his father. It's like actors don't like to do that usually.
而你们在这部剧里所做的一直是取笑你们自己。这就是我刚才说的盲点。乔克充满虚张声势，但在下一秒，就会变得无比脆弱，被他父亲的某种侮辱打击得粉碎。演员通常不喜欢那样做。
And yet that's where all the great stuff is. I'll never forget you told me once that sort of the... Correct me if I got it wrong, that the recipe that you had in mind was that your job as writers were to make these characters as unlikable as possible and that our job as actors is to make them as likable as possible.
然而，所有精彩的东西都在那里。我永远不会忘记你曾经对我说过，大概是——如果我记错了请纠正我——你脑海中的秘诀是，你们作为编剧的工作是让这些角色尽可能招人讨厌，而我们作为演员的工作是让它们尽可能讨人喜欢。
And the combination of those two things kind of allowed you guys to take these huge, what could be offensive swings, and then our ability hopefully to play ignorance or naivete would kind of give you the safe harbor to... First of all, I said that. You missed it and say that. Got it.
而这两件事结合起来，某种程度上允许你们做出这些巨大的、可能会冒犯人的尝试，然后我们扮演无知或天真的能力希望能在某种程度上为你们提供安全的避风港，去……首先，我说过这话吗？你漏掉了没说那个。明白了。
You might have said that. I said that. I believe that you said that because I have been credited with that before and it doesn't quite sound like me, but I think one of the things that I... The benefits that I had was that I knew like that in the DNA of the thing,
你可能说过。我说过。我相信你说过这话，因为我以前也被归功于说过这话，听起来不太像我的风格，但我认为我所拥有的优势之一是，我知道在那个东西的DNA里，
my characters were in the wrong. Like they... And they would get their comeuppance. But it was easier to have them be politically incorrect when the point was that they were in a miserable life condition and that they were in the wrong. So, yeah. So to that extent, I was trying to show,
我的角色是不对的。就像他们……而且他们会得到应有的报应。但当重点在于他们处于悲惨的生活境地并且他们本身就不对时，让他们显得政治不正确就会更容易一些。所以，是的。在这个程度上，我试图展现，
okay, there's selfishness here and there's self-absorption and narcissism. But these people are... Entitlement. Yeah, these are people who are saying and doing things that are sometimes aren't easy to stomach or sometimes distasteful or sometimes way off, way out of bounds.
好吧，这里有自私，有自我沉迷和自恋。但这些人是……有特权感。对，这些人说的话和做的事有时让人难以忍受，有时令人反感，有时完全越界，远远超出底线。
But what we're saying is, yeah, and that's what... Who these people are, that's what makes them so peculiar and strange and like... Yeah, they're not right. Yeah, they're not right at all. They're human beings. They're flawed human beings that are provincial
但我们要说的是，是的，这就是这些人，这正是他们如此古怪、奇特的原因，就像……是的，他们不正常。是的，他们一点都不正常。他们是人类。他们是有缺陷的人类，目光短浅、
and scared and don't want to lose their entitlement, you know? Mitch, did you ever... You talked about writing when you were in high school and writing comedy and stuff and you made that decision to not go into acting. Was there a moment? Seven or a moment? That's a great question.
充满恐惧，不想失去他们的特权，你知道的？米奇，你有没有……你谈到高中时写作和写喜剧之类的事情，你当时做出了不去做演员的决定。有没有那么一个瞬间？七个还是一个瞬间？这是个好问题。
Well, that's a great question. And just for you other guys, because you're all trying to figure out who's the best host, that's the best question that's been asked. An unfinished question is even qualifying as the best. I know what he's asking. What he's asking is, why weren't you a major movie star?
好吧，这真是个好问题。为了你们其他人，因为你们都在琢磨谁是最好的主持人，这是迄今为止被问到的最好的问题。一个还没问完的问题甚至都有资格被评为最好。我知道他在问什么。他在问，你为什么没有成为超级电影巨星？
And I'm going to tell you the choice that I made. Was there a moment that could have led to that? Yeah, I mean, I was less interested. I would have been... I don't know that I would have been considered an actor's actor. I think I would have been considered a major action movie star. And the reason I didn't go down that road... Mm-hmm.
我来告诉你我做出的选择。有没有哪个瞬间本可以通向那个方向？是的，我是说，我没那么感兴趣。我会成为——我不知道我是否会被认为是一个演技派演员。我想我会成为一个主要的动作片巨星。我没有走那条路的原因是——嗯哼。
Yeah, keep going. Quicker, faster. Well, okay, so quicker. So just the backstory is, there was an audition for the movie Taps. Sure. And my drama teacher wanted to send me to it. And I didn't...
对，继续说。更快，更迅速。好吧，那么更快。所以背景故事是，当时有一部电影叫《熄灯号》的试镜。没错。我的戏剧老师想让我去。而我没有……
The specifics don't matter. I think it was a Spanish class that took precedent. Well, let's talk about the specifics. But the end of the story is you didn't get it. Yeah, I didn't get it. I didn't go on it, but I also didn't get it. You didn't go on it. Okay.
具体细节不重要。我想是一堂西班牙语课占了先。好吧，我们来谈谈具体细节。但故事的结局是你没去。对，我没去。我没去面试，但我也没拿到角色。你没去面试。好吧。
Had I gone on it and gotten it, then look at me. I'm Tom Cruise over here. Who got the part? Oh, Tom Cruise got the part. Yeah, okay, okay. And Tom's great. Tom's great.
如果我去了并且拿到了角色，那么看看我。我就是这里的汤姆·克鲁斯。谁拿到了角色？哦，汤姆·克鲁斯拿到了角色。好吧，好吧。而且汤姆很棒。汤姆很棒。
I have no problem with Tom. Tom's great. Tom's talented. And he does a different thing than I do. But you would have denied the world the talents of Tom Cruise. No one would have known who Tom Cruise is. Or did you not... Tom and I are very different.
我对汤姆没有任何意见。汤姆很棒。汤姆很有才华。他做的事情跟我做的不一样。但你就会剥夺世界欣赏汤姆·克鲁斯才华的机会。没有人会知道汤姆·克鲁斯是谁。或者你没有……汤姆和我非常不同。
He could have, I don't know, maybe would have written a funny sitcom about four bachelors or something that lived together. But would you have seen yourself doing, making some of the same choices that Tom did in his career? I would have made most of the same choices. I would not have made... As you know, I would not have...
他本可以，我不知道，也许会写一部关于四个住在一起的单身汉的有趣情景喜剧什么的。但你会看到自己做过类似汤姆在职业生涯中做出的那些选择吗？我会做出大部分相同的选择。我不会做的是……如你所知，我不会……
This isn't quite professional, but I would not have divorced Nicole Kidman. I would have made that work. And for a very, very simple reason, I think she's very pretty. And I don't think you disrespect that. I don't think you just... Mitch, are you comfortable sharing with us
这有点不专业，但我不会和妮可·基德曼离婚。我会让那段婚姻维持下去。原因非常非常简单，我觉得她非常漂亮。我不认为你可以对那不屑一顾。我不认为你可以随随便便……米奇，你愿意跟我们分享一下，
what you're working on next or what you are excited about? We're talking about... We're talking about our Mission Impossible 7. But what I would be working on... I'm sorry, what I would be working on or what I am working on? I'm missing the shit.
你接下来在忙什么或者你对什么感到兴奋吗？我们在谈论……我们在谈论我们的《碟中谍7》。但我会去忙的……抱歉，是我会去忙的还是我正在忙的？我漏掉了那个屁。
But it would be MI7. Yeah, yeah, MI7. I got it. MI7. Well, the six left so many open-ended questions. MI, he even calls it MI. Yeah, we've never done... They've never done a guy riding a motorcycle underwater.
但那会是《碟中谍7》。对，对，《碟中谍7》。我明白了。《碟中谍7》。嗯，第六部留下了太多开放式的问题。碟中谍，他甚至管它叫MI。对，我们从来没拍过……他们从来没拍过一个人在水下骑摩托车。
So I think MI7 has some room to play in that space. Paddle wheels. Hey, Mitch, that question from Sean did get me thinking. And I'm going to go ahead and put you on the spot here on live podcast vision. What are the odds of Will and I ever working with you again? Are you working on anything that we could fit into?
所以我认为《碟中谍7》在这方面还有一些发挥空间。脚踏轮。嘿，米奇，肖恩的那个问题确实让我想到了。我要在现场播客的镜头前给你出个难题。威尔和我再次与你合作的几率有多大？你手头有什么我们可以适合的剧本吗？
I mean, it's just an apology. I just need the apology, guys. I mean, I can't do it without the apology. Oh, well, I'm sorry. Let me just give you a blanket apology. Why was that so hard? Any time you use it for anything you want. I mean, I would love to.
我是说，这只是一句道歉。我只需要你们的道歉，伙计们。我是说，没有道歉我做不到。哦，好吧，我很抱歉。让我直接给你一个全面道歉。为什么这那么难？任何时候你想用它做什么都行。我是说，我很乐意。
God, there's nothing I'd love more. I mean, that's one of the problems I was so spoiled by working with you guys and everybody on that show, really. Let's come up with a show right now. Let's have a little... So let's say, and Sean, you can be in it too. So it's three, are we brothers or are we coworkers? Sorry, hang on, hang on.
天哪，没有比这更让我乐意的了。我是说，问题之一就是我被你们和那部剧里的每个人惯坏了，真的。我们现在就想个剧本吧。让我们来个小……所以，假设，肖恩，你也可以参演。所以是三个，我们是兄弟还是同事？等等，等等，
It's set in LA. Okay, it's set in LA because we have families. And are we brothers or are we coworkers? Mitch, are we brothers or coworkers? I'm going to say brothers and coworkers. Brothers and coworkers? Great, love it. Okay.
故事设定在洛杉矶。好吧，设定在洛杉矶，因为我们都有家庭。我们是兄弟还是同事？米奇，我们是兄弟还是同事？我要说是兄弟兼同事。兄弟兼同事？太棒了，我喜欢。好吧。
And you're physically very abusive with each other. And this is where we get into a little bit of the three-studies territory. So forgive me. Physical comedy. You're pokers. It's familiar to me. You're pokers and you're prodders and you're pullers and you're sloppers. I quit hustling around you, too.
而且你们在肢体上对彼此非常粗暴。这就是我们要进入一点“三宝喜剧”领域的地方了。请原谅我。肢体喜剧。你们是爱戳人的。这我很熟悉。你们是戳戳捅捅、推推搡搡、拉拉扯扯的。我也别在你周围瞎胡闹了。
You're disturbing my club. Sean, that was the most amazing Larry Fine. I can't believe you even discovered that you knew how to do Larry Fine. I didn't. I used to do a lot. Have you ever heard him play piano? I have no doubt he can do a lot of different things. No, I used Billy West to talk to me how to talk like Larry.
你打扰到我的俱乐部了。肖恩，那是史上最棒的拉里·芬（模仿）。我真不敢相信你竟然发现自己会模仿拉里·芬。我不会。我以前经常模仿。你听过他弹钢琴吗？毫无疑问他能做很多不同的事情。不，我曾让比利·韦斯特教我怎么像拉里那样说话。
Oh, my God, that was... Because it's the same as Ren and Stimpy. He's the voice of Ren and Stimpy. And he said I used Larry from the three-studies to talk like Stimpy. So if you ever get stuck, just watch. But it was for... Do it, just do a little of it. Hey, I quit hustling around you, too. You're disturbing my coffee, bro.
哦，天哪，太……因为这和《莱恩和史丁比》一样。他是《莱恩和史丁比》的配音。他说我用《三宝喜剧》里的拉里来作为史丁比的说话腔调。所以如果你卡壳了，就去看那个。但那是为了……模仿一下，稍微模仿一点。嘿，我也别在你周围瞎胡闹了。你打扰到我的咖啡了，兄弟。
Wait, no, do it. No, do it. And how about how Will transformed himself into a horse? Like, do a little of it. That's hard. Do a little of the horse, Will. Do the horse. I've been doing it.
等等，不，模仿一下。不，模仿一下。还有威尔是怎么把自己变成一匹马的？来，稍微模仿一下。那太难了。威尔，稍微模仿一下那匹马。模仿那匹马。我一直在模仿。
I've been doing it. Oh, you have been doing it. This is the horse. That's what it sounds like on the show? This is the horse. I gotta watch that. Oh, yeah, I guess it is. Jason, you've never watched it.
我一直在模仿。哦，你一直在模仿。这就是那匹马。在剧里听起来就是这样吗？这就是那匹马。我得去看看那个。哦，对，我想是的。杰森，你从没看过。
When does Will get back? Can I talk to Will then? You've never... You've never... I stopped watching cartoons when I was, you know, a kid. Boy, that's a really tidy answer. That's really tidy. Hey, I'm waiting for a few hundred of them to be made
威尔什么时候回来？那我能跟威尔说话吗？你从来没……你从来没……我从我还是个……还是个孩子的时候就不看动画片了。天哪，真是个滴水不漏的回答。真是滴水不漏。嘿，我在等几百集制作出来，
so that I can really binge it. Oh, is that what you're doing? Your behavior is diabolical. Your behavior is diabolical, Jason. Listen, Sean has never seen Arrested Development mentioned. He didn't want to admit it. I have. I've seen the first three episodes.
这样我就可以一口气看个痛快了。哦，你是这么打算的？你的行为太反常了。你的行为太反常了，杰森。听着，肖恩从来没看过《发展受阻》这事儿是真的。他不想承认。我看过。我看过前三集。
It's hard to get around to watching something, particularly that we always had this problem with Arrested that people kind of thought it was a smart show. It was, you know, critics trying to be nice. I'm not kidding. I laughed out loud. The reason why I haven't watched it is because I'm fucking lazy.
很难抽出时间去看某些东西，尤其是我们对《发展受阻》一直有这样一个问题，就是人们觉得它是一部很聪明的剧。那是，你知道的，评论家在刻意表现友善。我没开玩笑。我当时笑出声了。我没看的原因是因为我他妈太懒了。
I don't watch anything. I read. I'm sorry. I read. I watch news stuff. I... What do you read? What do you... I'm curious.
我什么都不看。我阅读。我很抱歉。我阅读。我看新闻类的东西。我……你读什么？你……我很好奇。
What do you read? Right now, I'm reading The Mind-Body Connection. So, nonfiction you read mostly. I don't think Will reads a lot of nonfiction. I do read a lot of nonfiction. What about you, Mitch? Are you a reader? I am.
你读什么？现在，我在读《心灵身体连接》。所以你主要读非虚构作品。我觉得威尔不怎么读非虚构作品。我确实读很多非虚构作品。你呢，米奇？你是个爱读书的人吗？我是。
Fiction or non? Sort of both, but mostly nonfiction, I have to say. Mitch is a voracious reader. Mitch, one time, we were flying to London and he was reading that book. I remember us taking notes in it. He was reading the book about the... What is it?
虚构还是非虚构？两者都有点，但大多数是非虚构，我得承认。米奇是一个如饥似渴的读者。米奇，有一次，我们飞往伦敦，他就在读那本书。我记得我们在上面做笔记。他在读关于……那叫什么来着？
The China... What was it called? The China Study. The China Study. And so, it's like, you know, we leave LA. It's a 12-hour flight and we settle down and I fall asleep. I sleep the whole flight and we're just pulling it. And Mitch is there and he's got his lights on
中国……叫什么？《中国健康调查报告》。《中国健康调查报告》。所以，就像，你知道的，我们离开洛杉矶。这是一个12小时的飞行，我们安顿下来，我睡着了。我睡了整个航程，而我们正加速。米奇在那里，他开着灯，
and he's like... And he's been reading. He's in the exact same position as when we took off from LA and he's been taking notes and he's like, Hey, by the way, did you know that we shouldn't be eating any meat and we should also only be eating legume that are grown in our own backyards. And I'm like, how the fuck is going on?
他就像……他一直在阅读。他保持着和我们从洛杉矶起飞时一模一样的姿势，一直在做笔记，然后他说，嘿，顺便问一下，你知道我们不应该吃任何肉类，而且我们也应该只吃在我们自己后院种植的豆科植物吗？我心想，这他妈到底是怎么回事？
It really changed me until we were about like almost all the way to baggage claims. And I think there was some meat thing in pastry that we got a few of us. So you like that kind of stuff. You like... I do. And you know, neurology is everywhere right now.
它真的改变了我，直到我们几乎快要到行李提取处。而且我想我们后来还吃了几块酥皮肉馅饼，有几个人吃了。所以你喜欢那种东西。你喜欢……我喜欢。而且你知道，神经学现在到处都是。
Neurology is so interesting. You've always been into that though. That's been a big... That's brain stuff. It's... Yeah. Fascinating. Yeah.
神经学太有趣了。不过你一直对那个很感兴趣。那是个重大领域……那是关于大脑的东西。那是……太迷人了。对。
And just... I love it. It's just responsible for everything. Even our notions of ourselves and... Well, and you know, our gut, it's our second brain match. I love this character. Yeah. First of all, you've been reading up on neurology for years.
而且只要……我太喜欢了。它简直是一切的主宰。甚至包括我们对自己的看法以及……好吧，你知道的，我们的肠道，那是我们的第二个大脑，米奇。我喜欢这个角色。对。首先，你研究神经学好几年了。
Teach me something about neurology, Mitch, right now. No, I think this is... By the way, this is interesting. I think one of the things I love about Mitch, about the way that you write and the way that you approach characters and story is, you do read a lot about, not just about how the brain works,
现在就教我一些关于神经学的知识，米奇。不，我认为这是……顺便说一句，这很有趣。我认为我喜欢米奇的一点，关于你的写作方式以及你接触角色和故事的方式是，你确实读了很多书，不仅是关于大脑如何运作的，
but about how people work. And I think all that shit informs your writing in ways that you don't... You're not even necessarily conscious of. It might. The China study taught you anything. But no, but I mean, you do. You love that shit.
还有关于人是如何运作的。我认为所有这些乱七八糟的东西都以你甚至没有意识到的方式滋养了你的写作。也许吧。《中国健康调查报告》教会了你什么。不，但是我的意思是，你确实。你喜欢那些乱七八糟的东西。
It's the kind of shit that you talk about. You'll constantly go, do you know that when people have a relationship with another person, that they have made a connection and you'll bring up something that strikes you, and I think it makes its way into your characters? I mean, that particular one was just a way of saying,
那是你会谈论的那种东西。你会经常说，你知道吗，当人们与另一个人建立关系时，他们就建立了一种连接，然后你会提出一些让你震惊的事情，而我认为这些事情最终进入了你的角色中？我是说，那次纯粹只是想说，
you know, include me in things. Well, be my friend. No, no, but you know what I mean. I could use a friend. I'll be happier. And that will make me happier. There is a level of intelligence that is just unbelievable with your writing.
你知道的，把我算进去。好吧，做我的朋友。不，不，但你知道我的意思。我需要一个朋友。我会更高兴。那会让我更高兴。有一种智商，在你的写作中简直是不可思议的。
Do you think that you gave enough of that intelligence to your offspring? I was talking about this the other day. This is a pivot to a new subject. I don't want to hurt anybody with whiplash, but I was talking to somebody the other day about nature versus nurture, and you really can't really conduct that study
你觉得你把那种智商足够多地分给你的后代了吗？我前几天还在谈论这个。这是一个新话题的切入点。我不想让任何人扭伤脖子，但我前几天跟某人谈论先天与后育，你真的无法在家里进行这种研究，
inside your house until you have two children and you do have two beautiful daughters. And so do you see the like, oh, well, this one got a lot of this and this one got a lot of that. Are they, are they, are they, they're both out of the house now, right? No, they both been home.
除非你有两个孩子，而你确实有两个漂亮的女儿。所以你有没有看到那种，哦，好吧，这个继承了这个很多，那个继承了那个很多。她们，她们，她们，现在都搬出去了吧？没有，她们都还在家。
They should have been out of the house, but they both been home because of COVID. So it's been kind of a blessing, but a blessing that I don't realize is a blessing. Like it's just something I know I'm going to look back on and think, God, I had that little gift. Were you enjoying the empty nesting?
她们本来应该搬出去的，但因为新冠疫情，她们俩都一直呆在家。所以这有点像是一种祝福，但却是一种我没有意识到是祝福的祝福。就像我知道我以后回想起来会觉得，天哪，我曾有过那样一份小礼物。你当时享受空巢期吗？
And now, and now- We never got a chance to. Oh, really? Never happened. Yeah, we never had a chance. We never had a chance. But, you know, don't you discover, I think that the biggest illusion
而现在，现在——我们根本没机会。哦，真的吗？从来没发生过。对，我们从来没机会。我们从来没机会。但是，你知道的，难道你没发现，我认为最大的幻觉是
is that these children take after us. I think they are just, they are just their own people. Oh, you really think that? I do, but it's an illusion. It's a really prevalent illusion. And particularly with traits that maybe you don't like about yourself,
这些孩子会模仿我们。我觉得他们只是，他们只是他们自己。哦，你真的这么认为吗？我这么认为，但这是一种错觉。这是一种非常普遍的错觉。特别是对于那些你可能不喜欢自己身上的特质，
that I, you know, maybe because I've finished in comedy or maybe just because I'm a jerk, I tend to like see flaws all the time. You know, I see flaws in people. I see, I see cliches that are used. I see behavior that, you know, and I can be very critical of that.
我，你知道的，也许是因为我从事喜剧，或者也许只是因为我这人有点混蛋，我总是倾向于看到缺点。你知道的，我在别人身上看到缺点。我看到人们使用的老套路。我看到一些行为，你知道的，对此我可能会非常挑剔。
And then I'll see my younger daughter will have a really sharp, quick response about somebody struggling to get into a, you know, past a car door or something and say, oh, look at this. Here we go. Look at this. You know, I'm like, yeah, that's,
然后我会看到我的小女儿对某个挣扎着想要打开车门或类似东西的人做出非常尖锐、迅速的反应，然后说：“哦，看这个。来吧。看这个。”你知道的，我就想，是的，那，
so it feels like that's from me. That's interesting though, because I never, I was thought about that like- That's wiring. I mean, listen, we know that negative experiences are far more powerful than positive experiences. And there's, you know, an evolutionary
所以感觉那是遗传自我。不过这很有趣，因为我从来没想过那像——那是思维回路。我是说，听着，我们知道负面经历比正面经历的影响力要强大得多。而且你知道的，这有一个进化上的
reason for that. And the differential rate of those that survive that pay attention to negative experiences. And so, you know, you know, that you can influence a child for the worse. That's undeniable. Yeah.
原因。以及那些关注负面经历并因此得以生存的人的不同生存率。所以，你知道的，你知道你可以把一个孩子往坏的方向影响。这是不可否认的。是的。
Giving them praise and undue accolades is not that beneficial because- It's not. Evolutionarily speaking, the human body kind of like discounts those things almost immediately, right? Yeah. There's been actually a lot of studies
给予他们赞扬和过度的称赞并没有太大益处，因为——确实如此。从进化论的角度来看，人类身体几乎会立即对这些事情打折扣，对吧？是的。事实上有很多研究，
that I, you know, won't be able to quote here, but that about, you know, talk about things that are, that are unintuitive. You're not supposed to tell children that they're smart. Like smart is really not a great thing to tell a kid like, oh, you got that
虽然我在这里可能引用不出来，但关于，你知道的，谈论那些反直觉的事情。你不应该告诉孩子们他们很聪明。就像“聪明”真的不是一件适合告诉孩子的好事，比如，哦，你答
right. You're really smart. They've done tests where kids that are told that are smart, like they're given, they take third graders and they give half of them, they give me each the same test. They tell half of them, hey,
对了。你真的很聪明。他们做过测试，对被告知很聪明的小孩——比如他们找来三年级学生，把他们分成两半，给两半人做同样的测试。他们告诉其中一半人：“嘿，
you did well, you're smart. And they tell the other half, hey, you did well, you really work hard. You don't give up. Then they give those same kids a fifth grade math test, which they couldn't possibly finish. They don't have the skills here,
你做得很好，你很聪明。”他们告诉另一半人：“嘿，你做得很好，你真的很努力。你没有放弃。”然后他们给这些同样的孩子做了一份五年级的数学测试，那是他们根本不可能完成的。他们没有这方面的技能，
the tools. The kids that were told, hey, you're really smart, they give up on it much faster, almost 100% of people stop taking the things and say, this is stupid. I don't like it because they, they have something to lose now.
没有这些工具。那些被告知“嘿，你真的很聪明”的孩子，放弃得要快得多，几乎100%的人都不做那些题目了，并说：“这太蠢了。我不喜欢它。”因为他们，他们现在有了可以失去的东西。
They, they have, I'm smart to lose. And the kids that weren't told that, but were told, well, you work hard, well, they tend to stay with that test longer and get some benefit from it. Is it kind of like I've been told I'm smart, so I don't have to try? Like I already did that.
他们有了，我需要维持“聪明”这个人设。而那些没有被告知那个，而是被告知“嗯，你很努力”的孩子，他们往往会在那个测试上坚持更久，并从中得到一些好处。这有点像“既然别人说我很聪明，所以我就不用去尝试了”？就像我已经做过了一样？
I think it's probably more that you don't, I mean, I have a lot of this, like I worry about doing something that's not good enough. I worry about- Well, we're going to edit this. With, oh, okay, great, great. And who gets edited in for me?
我想这可能更多是因为你不会，我的意思是，我身上有很多这种特质，比如我担心自己做的事情不够好。我担心——嗯，我们要剪掉这个。带着，哦，好吧，太棒了，太棒了。那谁会被剪进我的片段里？
But you can imagine that, that you would then go to take a language class or, or, or learn the piano or a skill that you can't be good at instantly unless there's just some alternate wiring that's going on that gives you that special ability. And, you know, you, you take three piano lessons. You say, this is stupid.
但你可以想象，你接下来去上语言课，或者学钢琴，或者学习一项你无法立刻精通的技能，除非脑子里有某种备用的神经回路能赋予你那种特殊的能力。然后，你知道的，你上了三节钢琴课，
I'm not going to, I can't do this because you haven't been praised for your determination and your forbearance. You know, you've been praised for just already being able to do something. And we can't already do something. Yeah. Right.
你就会说：“这太蠢了。我做不到，我干不了这个。”因为你并没有因为你的决心和毅力而受到表扬，你知道的，你只是因为已经能够做成某事而受到表扬。而我们不可能什么事都已经会做了。对吧。
Right. Yeah. You don't know anything till you learn it. Yeah. To your taught it. But I have to reteach myself that all the time. I mean, a lot of that has to do with, like, pushing yourself to be curious. I'll start a project and I'll think,
对。是的。在你学会之前你什么都不知道。是的。直到有人教你。但我必须时刻提醒自己重新学习这一点。我的意思是，这很大程度上与逼迫自己保持好奇心有关。我会开始一个项目，然后我会想，
oh, this isn't going to be good, though. This isn't going to be good. Or it's too similar to something else. And I'll have to kind of shut off that voice and tell myself to be curious about the experience of this and not to focus on that result. And to just see if there's something along the way in the journey of putting it together that,
哦，不过这不会是个好东西。这不会是个好作品。或者它跟别的什么东西太像了。然后我不得不掐断那个声音，告诉自己要对这段经历本身保持好奇，而不是去关注那个结果。只是去看看在把它拼凑起来的旅程中，
that is beneficial. I love that. And so to that point, are you, do you have something that you're working on that you love that you're going to take out soon? Or are you? There are a few things. Tough to talk about this because I'm working
是否有某个部分是有益的。我太喜欢这个了。那么说到这里，你有没有什么正在进行的、你很热爱并且很快就会推出的项目？还是说？有一些。很难谈论这个，因为我在和
with some other people and I don't want to jeopardize it. But there are a few things that I, the stuff that I'm most. We're going to have to read. The stuff that I'm most interested in doing and that I'm telling you we should do together is stuff that breaks the form a little bit. Because I think you'd need,
其他人合作，我不想搞砸它。但有几件事，我最——我们得剪掉。我最感兴趣去做的事情，也是我正跟你说我们应该一起做的事情，是一些稍微打破常规的东西。因为我觉得你需要，
we've got to shake it up a little bit. Yeah, I agree. And, you know, whether things, I mean, you guys all have, I think there's a way to redo the multicam with like a lot more improv in it and a lot more. I'm dying to do that. You know, yeah, you and I talk about that, Jason.
我们得稍微震撼一下。是的，我同意。而且，你知道的，不管事情，我是说，你们所有人都，我觉得有一种方法可以重拍多机位喜剧，里面加入更多即兴表演，还有更多——我太渴望这么做了。你知道的，是的，你和我谈过这个，杰森。
Connect with the audience. Wait, who woke up Will? Somebody woke up Will. No, Will, not connect with the audience. Back to bed. Feel the laughter. No, okay. Well, a little bit of feel the laughter.
与观众连接。等等，谁把威尔叫醒了？有人把威尔叫醒了。不，威尔，不是与观众连接。回去睡觉。感受笑声。不，好吧。好吧，稍微感受一下笑声。
Break the form. And I remember I think that was what was fun about when we were all working together and there were so many grand aspirations that we never did. Like, do you remember, I was thinking about this yesterday, when we were trying to get David Cross's character,
打破常规。我记得我觉得这正是我们以前一起工作时最有趣的地方，当时有那么多我们从未实现的宏大抱负。就像，你还记得吗，我昨天还在想这个，当我们试图让大卫·克罗斯的角色——
who was an actor and want to be actor, Tobias, to actually appear on house as a regular as Tobias, like the actor Tobias is. And that on our show, he would be like going off to work and, you know, we'd be behind the scenes of their show. And on their show, it would just be an actor. It just wasn't very good.
一个演员兼演员梦患者托比亚斯（Tobias），真正作为常驻演员出现在《豪斯医生》里，扮演托比亚斯本人时，就像演员托比亚斯那样。在我们的节目中，他会去上班，你知道的，我们会看到他们节目幕后。而在他们的节目里，他就只是个演员。只是演得不太好。
But it wouldn't have to carry a lot of pipe or anything. And I remember this show runner saying, like, well, why are we the fake world? Because you share the stage next to us. Exactly. Well, we want to be the real world and have you be the fake world. It's like, no, just be.
但不需要承担太多主线任务什么的。我记得当时有个剧集运作人说：“好吧，为什么我们是假的世界？因为你们和我们的舞台挨着。”没错。好吧，我们想成为真实的世界，让你们成为假的世界。这就好比，不，你们才该是那个。
It's funnier. But that's the stuff that, you know, remember we were, the other thing we were going to do like that was we were going to do a live show in between, like we were going to do a two-part season of Arrested Development on Netflix.
这样更有趣。但这就是那些，你知道的，还记得我们当时要做的吗，另一件类似的事是，我们打算在中间做一场直播秀，就像我们要为网飞制作两部分的《发展受阻》第四季。
And then in the middle of it, like the characters were going to do this live show, this rally to fundraise for Buster. And then we were going to actually do the live show. Oh, that's cool. That's a good idea. Raising money for themselves and then air that as a special. And I don't know, that's the stuff.
然后在中间，就像剧中的角色们要办这场直播秀，这场为巴斯特（Buster）筹款的集会。然后我们要真正地把这场直播秀办出来。哦，那太酷了。是个好主意。为他们自己筹钱，然后把那作为一期特辑播出。我不知道，这就是那些——
Maybe it's just avoidance of the actual hard job of just writing characters and letting them be funny. But like, I do find that that's the stuff that appeals to me. Like, let's do two shows and have them interact somehow. Mitch, do you sometimes get distracted from having to do that shit, get distracted by like a funny idea?
也许这只是在逃避写角色并让他们变搞笑这份真正的难差事？但我的确发现这就是吸引我的东西。比如，让我们拍两部剧，然后让他们以某种方式互动。米奇（Mitch），你有时会不会被某个搞笑的点子吸引，从而分心不去干那些狗屁活？
Then you just like, this seems like so much more fun than the hard work of what I'm doing right now. I mean, I think that is the big secret to like comedy writing and we've had this experience together is like, everything is just about what's funny. You know, you kind of after the fact, you engineer what you're getting at and what the character's growth means and all that.
然后你就觉得，这比我手头正在干的这件苦差事有趣多了？我的意思是，我觉得这就是喜剧写作的终极秘密，我们俩有过这种共同经历，那就是：一切都只关乎什么好笑。你知道的，事后你才会去构思你到底想表达什么、角色的成长意味着什么，诸如此类。
But really it starts with, what would be funny? Mitch, what about, what about, what would you say to a 12 episode, I'm not offering this yet. So don't say like sold. I'm in. Okay, sorry. Oh shit. No, I'm saying don't say, don't say I'm in.
但实际上，它始于：什么会好笑？米奇，如果我说，如果是一份12集的订单——我还没正式提供这个哦。所以别说什么“已售出”。我加入。好吧，抱歉。哦操。不，我是说别说，别说我加入。
To a 12 episode order of... Let's do it. Multi... Pfft. I didn't say sold. I said, let's do it. You did it. You did say let's do it.
对于一部12集的...我们干吧。多机位...噗。我没说已售出。我说，我们干吧。你确实说了。你确实说过“我们干吧”。
12 episode of multi-cam episodes of Arrested. Oh God, I was hoping you were gonna say that. I'm in. Oh, that would be fantastic. Yeah. Do the sitcom version with a live studio audience. Just do an alternate thing. Yeah.
12集的《发展受阻》多机位剧集。哦天哪，我正希望你这么说呢。我加入。哦，那太棒了。是的。做情景喜剧版，带现场演播室观众。就搞个另类版本。是的。
And then like... Yeah, alternate. And then we will borrow a little from WandaVision and we'll make it like, oh, it's all through time. Yeah. No, I always thought our show would work as a multi-cam. Because who plays Lucille Bluth? I know.
然后像……是的，另类版本。然后我们会借鉴一点《旺达幻视》的元素，把它弄得像是，哦，它贯穿了所有时间线。是的。不，我一直觉得我们的节目拍成多机位会很管用。因为谁来演露西尔·布鲁斯（Lucille Bluth）？我知道。
Sean Hayes. Sean Hayes. Oh my God. It's there and you're in the face. Yep. Sean Hayes. Slap it, wig on me. It's just another Tuesday.
肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes）。肖恩·海斯。哦天哪。就在那儿，就在你脸上。没错。肖恩·海斯。给我拍上，戴上假发。这不过是又一个周二。
Well, we're not gonna slap it. We're gonna glue. We're gonna do a bald cap first. Yeah, I think we want the wig to be right. It would make as much sense as... We want the wig to be really right. We got great... Go ahead.
好吧，我们不用拍的。我们要用胶水粘。我们先弄个光头套。是的，我觉得我们要确保假发戴对。这和……我们想让假发非常完美。我们有棒极了的……说吧。
Sorry, Jason. Yeah, who played... Who did you play? I'm just saying we have good wig people. Just take a wig off, Sean, and, you know, obviously put another better wig on him and just shoot the thing. Or just take one off and leave the one that's on underneath it.
抱歉，杰森。是的，谁演的……你演的谁？我只是说我们有很棒的假发师。只要摘掉肖恩的假发，然后，你知道的，显然给他换上另一顶更好的假发，然后开拍就行。或者摘掉一顶，留下里面原本戴着的那顶。
Right, well, you're... Because you're double. Let's do a fucking... Let's do... Fuck. A rested development. Can I call you Milt? Is that a okay name?
好吧，你……因为你是替身。让我们搞个他妈的……让我们搞个……操。《发展受阻》。我能叫你米尔特（Milt）吗？这是一个可以的名字吗？
Milt. Milt. Sure. Yeah, Sean. Sean, are you okay with Milt? Yeah, Milt. We're gonna go all the way back to Three Camera. And it's gonna be Dolly's.
米尔特。米尔特。当然。是的，肖恩。肖恩，你介意叫米尔特吗？是的，米尔特。我们要全面回归三机位。而且要有摇臂。
Yeah? Yeah. Multi-cam arrested. Live band. Why not? Let's do it. Let's do... Let's do multi-cam and behind the scenes of a multi-cam
是吗？对。多机位《发展受阻》。现场乐队。为什么不呢？我们干吧。让我们拍……让我们拍多机位以及多机位的幕后花絮，
or something at the same show. We don't need to be. The whole sort of... What do they call it when cast come back together? Reunion. A reunion. Yeah, those are all the rage now. And you still don't think you should read, huh?
或者同一档节目里的其他东西。我们不需要。整个那种……他们把演员重新聚在一起叫什么来着？重聚。一场重聚。是的，现在那些可太火了。你还是觉得你不该读，对吧？
Some words are tough for me. Yeah, we'll do one of those and then we'll roll it right into a quick 22-minute episode. We'll just walk right over. I love it. I love it. And we'll get everybody back together. We'll get Dr. House. We'll get Tobias.
有些词对我来说挺难的。是的，我们搞一个那样的，然后马上转入一个22分钟的快节奏单集。我们直接走过去。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我们会把大家都聚齐。我们会请到豪斯医生。我们会请到托比亚斯。
We'll get... We're not getting fucking Dr. House. We're all right. They said no. What about when Tobias' hair transplant rejected the... Graff versus host. Graff versus host. David crosses commitment to every scene.
我们会……我们才不请他妈的豪斯医生。我们挺好的。他们拒绝了。那次托比亚斯的植发产生排异反应时……移植物抗宿主病。移植物抗宿主病。大卫·克罗斯对每一个镜头都无比投入。
Oh, god damn it. Everybody was funny in the thing. But David was so... And I think David might be the most unlike his character. Could be, yeah. Everybody was unlike their character. Yeah, it could be. But very similar in his comfort with being offbeat.
哦，该死。每个人在里面都很搞笑。但大卫是那么的……而且我觉得大卫可能最不像他扮演的角色。有可能，是的。每个人都不像他们的角色。是的，有可能。但他在接受离经叛道的事物这方面非常相似。
Yeah, I know. But he's very offbeat and he's very cool. And Tobias is just not offbeat and uncool. Yeah, yeah. We all know who is closest to their character. Don't say it. And that's our cue. And that's our cue.
是的，我知道。但他非常离经叛道，而且他很酷。而托比亚斯一点也不离经叛道，而且很不酷。对，对。我们都知道谁和自己的角色最像。别说出来。这就是我们的暗示。这就是我们的暗示。
Mitch, thank you so much for being here. I'm going to pick up the China story. And I'm going to check my email to see if I got about everything's relative. Yeah, you can see if you got the yes on that. Check my messages. And I will be by your house later to drop off a pie. You know what?
米奇，非常感谢你能来。我要接着聊中国的故事了。我要去查查邮件，看看我有没有收到关于《万物皆相对》的消息。对，你可以看看你有没有得到那边的肯定回复。查查我的信息。我稍后会去你家一趟，送个派。你知道吗？
Because of COVID, we just use the pie slot now, which is around the sides. Okay, great. You see, it's just pie. You just put it in a pie slot? You put it in a pie slot? We could fit in a wig fitting when I'm over. I would love to do that.
因为疫情，我们现在只用派槽了，就在侧面。哦，太棒了。你看，这只是派。你直接把它放进派槽里？你把它放进派槽里？我过去的时候可以顺便量个假发尺寸。我很乐意这么做。
John, I'd love to, it's going to sound creepy, but I'd love to get my hands on you. Not creepy at all. Here's the sad part. That doesn't sound creepy at all. Okay, good. I have my fingers crossed. You just can't see it.
约翰，我很乐意——听起来可能有点毛骨悚然，但我很想把手搭在你身上。一点也不毛骨悚然。悲哀的部分来了。听起来一点也不毛骨悚然。好吧，很好。我正双手合十呢。只是你看不到。
It's so nice to meet you, though. And my friends, I love you. Love you, Mitch. I love you, too. Love you, love you, love you. Say hello to Mary Jo, please. Yes, I will. Thank you.
不过很高兴见到你。还有我的朋友们，我爱你们。爱你，米奇。我也爱你。爱你，爱你，爱你。请替我向玛丽·乔（Mary Jo）问好。好的，我会的。谢谢。
This has been the greatest first part of an interview that we've ever done. We're going to pick this up at a later date. We're going to have you back in like six months. We need to have more mature roots in our life. Right on. Yeah. All right, guys.
这是我们做过的最棒的访谈的第一部分。我们会在晚些时候继续这个话题。我们会在大概六个月后请你回来。我们需要在生活中拥有更成熟的根基。没错。是的。好吧，伙计们。
Love you, pal. Love you the best. I'll be the best. Bye. Guys, I don't know him obviously like you do. I love that man. Warm, friendly, hilarious. He's the funniest.
爱你们，老兄。最爱你们。我是最棒的。再见。伙计们，虽然我显然不像你们那样了解他。我太爱那个人了。温暖、友好、 hilarious（滑稽）。他最搞笑了。
The funniest, nicest, smartest, most talented. He's the funniest. I mean, I truly would have done that show for ever. I'm jealous. Just because of him and because of all the people, 100% of the people that were there in front of the camera and off, just a great, great.
最搞笑、最友好、最聪明、最有才华。他最搞笑了。我是说，我真的愿意永远拍那部剧。我很嫉妒。仅仅是因为他，以及所有那些人，100%在镜头前和幕后的人，都是伟大、伟大的人。
Love it. Very fortunate period in my life for sure. Will, what do you think? You hated the whole experience, didn't you? Yeah. Did you not like it? Yeah, I hated it. Every day, I remember every day going on to a lot at Fox
太棒了。我人生中非常幸运的一段时期，真的。威尔，你怎么看？你讨厌整个经历，对吧？是的。你不喜欢吗？是的，我恨透了。每天，我记得每天去福克斯的片场，
and just thinking, every day thinking, I can't believe I get to do this today. That's so great. I love that. Every fucking day was the best. And even the days where like I took a dump in Jason's trailer and turned the heat up. And I got you back by putting the tuna salad up in your closet
然后都在想，每天都在想，我简直不敢相信我今天能做这个。太棒了。我太喜欢了。他妈的每一天都是最棒的。甚至包括我在杰森的房车里拉了一堆屎并把暖气开到最高的那几天。那我通过把金枪鱼沙拉塞进你衣柜里报复了你，
you couldn't find for a few months, right? That's true. Did you really do that? Yeah, almost a year in my trailers. And I was like screaming at the teamsters, can I get a new trailer for God's sake? I never screamed. I never screamed at a teamster.
让你几个月都找不到，对吧？真的吗？你真的那样做了？是的，在我房车里放了快一年。然后我冲着卡车司机工会的人大吼大叫：“看在上帝的份上，我能不能换个新房车？”我从来没吼过。我从来没冲卡车司机工会的人吼过。
But it was such a great experience. And it was the people. We got to, he led from the top with this just great energy. And it was always about, there was such a safety net there of, there was no wrong. There was no wrong answer. It was just kind of felt like you were always just trying to do the funniest version of the scene.
但那真的是一段美妙的经历。而且是因为那些人。我们能够，他以身作则，带着那种极好的能量引领大家。而且总是围绕着——那里有一个极好的安全网，没有什么是错的。没有错误的答案。感觉你好像总是试图去拍出场景中最搞笑的版本。
Yeah. And you could kind of try anything. He seems like a really fun guy that you'd want to hang out with that you'd maybe want to go grab a bite. A bite with a bite. I'll allow it. Bye. Smart.
是的。而且你可以尝试任何事。他看起来像个非常有趣的人，你会想和他一起闲逛，也许还想去吃个便饭。吃个便饭，加个便饭。我批准了。再见。聪明。
Yes. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。聪明。聪明。这集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。